thank you
my lords
motion for debate
the principles behind the UK Asylum and
Refugee policy and the response to the
challenges of forced migration
the Lord Archbishop of Canterbury
my lords I am very grateful to the usual
channels for facilitating this debate
and to those who've had to work extra
hard amongst the staff of the house to
come in today and to so many noble Lords
for being present today thank you very
much indeed
I look forward to hearing the maiden
speeches of the right Reverend prelate
the bishop of Leicester the noble Lord
Lord sahota and the noble baroness
baroness twicross on this subject
this will not be a sermon as my last
as my last uh
well-attended sermon was four and a half
minutes that may be a disappointment to
Noble Lord
but it is nevertheless underpinned by
deeply
held spiritual principles deriving from
The Words of Christ
beginning
over a thousand years ago in terms of
our policy
and the application of them
the last time I delivered one on this
sermon on this subject it gained more
than the usual attention
but so much so that I see some of our
newspapers this week have rebutted the
arguments I am about to make before I'd
had a chance to deliver them or even for
that matter to prepare them I'm glad
they have such Gifts of mind reading
get your rebuttal in first Willie John
McBride captain of the 1974 invincibles
almost told his teammates I think he
said retaliation
for the avoidance of doubt my intention
today is to examine some of the moral
considerations which should drive our
policies in this area and then to
propose some practical ways forward for
the short medium and long term
the church is often and quite often
rightly criticized for talking about
morality in isolation from the
complexity of the real world
but when it comes to the treatment of
refugees and those seeking Asylum it is
the church both here and abroad which is
doing so much of the heavy lifting of
meeting and supporting of healing and
advocacy right around the world we look
into the faces we listen to the voices
and we speak from that experience
two weeks ago I visited Mozambique to
inaugurate a new province in the
Anglican communion well there we went up
north to the area where Isis is very
active indeed
it's a beautiful country generous people
recovering from Civil War are now facing
an atrocious extremist Insurgency
I met a young woman who had fled dyesh
she had seen beheadings in her Village
she herself had been raped
and then she'd watched them smash
her three-month-old baby's head against
a tree
that is one reality
last week in Ukraine
standing by a mass grave I met people
who with astonishing resolve face a
winter under Russian bombardment
explicitly to destroy civilian
infrastructure
a winter where next month it will fall
probably to minus 20 degrees and they
will have neither electricity
nor because of that water
and the ability to heat
these are two images of suffering
which could be replicated in over 50
other countries around the world
we know and I want to make that
absolutely clear and underline it
that Britain can neither res resolve
these problems by ourselves
nor can or should we take everyone who
flees such Devastation it is beyond our
capacity
but we do need to take a lead
how we shape our policies must look into
the faces and must listen to the voices
and recognition of human dignity is the
first principle which must underpin our
Asylum policy a hostile environment is
an immoral environment
each human being has an inherent and
immeasurable worth regardless of their
status wealth Heritage or background
the Book of Genesis tells us God created
Mankind in his own image
in the 25th chapter of the Gospel of
Saint Matthew in the parable of the
sheep and goats Jesus tells his
followers about those who are strangers
whatever you did for one of the least of
these brothers and sisters of mine you
did for me
care for the stranger has long been
embedded in societies of Christian and
Jewish roots and of other faiths right
round the world
the welcome arrival in the UK of other
religious faiths deepens these
traditions of compassion
a compassionate Asylum system is one
that sees the faces of those in need and
listens to their voices
a compassionate system does not mean
open borders but a disposition of
generosity and a Readiness to welcome
those whose need is genuine and where we
are able to meet that need it also means
compassion and generosity to those
communities that will receive refugees
which are often neglected and forgotten
and I've seen this with my own eyes
around the diocese I serve in East Kent
the Diocese of Canterbury which perhaps
Bears the heaviest weight of this great
crisis
a compassionate policy is one that has
confidence to regret reject the shrill
narratives that all who come to us for
help should be treated as lies
scroungers or less than fully human
compassion is not weakness or naivety
it recognizes the impact on receiving
communities which includes the need to
limit numbers and maintain security and
Order
compassion means ending the criminal
activity of people's Smugglers
perhaps one of the biggest industries in
the world after drug smuggling
but it must distinguish between victims
seeking help and criminals who exploit
them
so much of the public and political
debate on migration is driven by fear my
lords linked to change and a fear of
loss of control
some of these fears are understandable
many people are concerned that their
communities and local Services risk
being overwhelmed
in East Kent Local Schools businesses
and hospitals have risen amazingly and
magnificently to the challenge
they are in a line our border Force have
carried out their Mandate of saving life
at Sea despite the disgraceful
politicization of their work by some
there is real pressure on housing
schools and GP surgeries to which they
respond superbly
but refugees have not by the way caused
our housing crisis
we are around 40 years behind in our
investment in housing stock there would
be a crisis anyway
and the number of Asylum Seekers has
dropped in the past two decades in 2021
there were 48 540 Asylum applications
made in the UK in 2002 that was 84
132 almost twice as much
other countries have taken significantly
more refugees
in the year ending September 21 Germany
received over 127
000 applications France over 96
000. it is not a competition my lords
but we do need to face the fact that the
UK ranked only 18 1 8. in Europe for our
intake of Asylum applications per head
of the population in that period
and it cannot be repeated enough four
out of five refugees stay in their
region of displacement hosted by Nations
far poorer than themselves
speak to Uganda
or other countries in that area
and they will say forty five thousand
that's a rounding error
when we fail to challenge the harmful
rhetoric that refugees are the cause of
this country's ills
then they should that they should be
treated as problems not people
Invaders to be tackled and deterred we
deny the essential value and dignity of
fellow human beings
the right to seek Asylum and the duty of
the global Community together to protect
refugees has been politically degraded
in this country when it should be a
positive source of pride
I'm not only addressing the government
front bench
this has been a decades long downward
side over successive labor conservative
and Coalition governments
my lords you would expect me to say
something about the Rwanda policy
we cannot separate the policy from the
moral arguments
the government did not do this when it
announced the policy in Holy Week this
year
the most sacred week of the Christian
calendar on Monday Thursday when in
Christian belief Jesus was washing his
disciples feet including Judas Iscariot
and the prime minister of the time
gave a speech in which he used the word
compassion six times and described the
policy as the morally right thing to do
in my sermon on Easter Sunday I gave a
brief view of this it was five lines in
a
three page sermon
and shortly after every one of my
colleagues on these benches issued a
statement concluding that this was an
immoral policy that shames Britain
it is very rare on these benches that
were United on almost anything
I congratulate the prime minister of
managing to unite the bishop the bench
of Bishops what a miracle
it's a good reason for the other 53 of
the population to click the census
saying they are Christians
the government has said that the Rwanda
policy aims to deter people arriving in
the UK through illegal dangerous or
unnecessary methods there is little or
no evidence that this deterrence or the
hostile environment works the
government's own impact assessment
confirms that
the complaint I make is not about Rwanda
a country I know well and in which there
is much that I admire
a compassionate policy is one that
recognizes we have a share of global
responsibility
Outsourcing our share creates more
opportunities for people Smugglers to
operate in and around Rwanda it's not a
solution it's a mistake and it will be a
failure
furthermore the desire for orderly
migration to discourage people from
skipping the queue is absurd if there is
no legal cue
appoint the Home Secretary and her
officials recently conceded at the home
Affairs Select Committee in the Commons
there is no safe or regular route for an
Iranian Christian or a gay man a woman
from Eritrea to come to the UK to claim
Asylum yet both would be highly likely
to have a valid claim if they got you
unless you're coming from Ukraine
Afghanistan Syria or Hong Kong and that
by the way is not Asylum but Financial
visas or are eligible for the
restrictive family reunion criteria
there is no regular route that you can
use
it was reported this month that not one
person has been accepted and evacuated
from Afghanistan under the Afghan
citizens resettlement scheme the
minister has very kindly written to me
to correct that report which was in the
newspapers last Sunday I hope in his
response that he will clarify that
correction for the whole house
when migrants arrive here our system is
grossly wasteful in both human and
financial terms control has become
cruelty staggering inefficiencies by
successive governments trap people in
limbo at incredible expense to the
taxpayer in the system for years unable
to build a life or to contribute to our
society
I recently came across someone who'd
been in the Asylum system for 14 years
14 years my lords
home Affairs select committee evidence
shows that of all the people who arrived
in the UK and by boat and claimed asylum
in 2021 only four percent of claims had
been processed by the home office by
October 2022
this does not treat people with dignity
or compassion and nor is it control
as well as the overcrowded and
disease-ridden conditions exposed
recently which the government is now
addressing camps and hotel accommodation
keep migrants separate from the rest of
the community this segregation feeds
concerns about lack of control it fails
to treat Asylum Seekers and refugees as
Neighbors
who are to be loved or citizens in
waiting we miss out on the gifts they
bring and want to contribute I met
someone yesterday who is now a citizen
incredibly proud of his citizenship and
contributing enormously to our society
working with people in prison to help
them go straight when they come out
solidarity with others is built by
contact and building relationships
instead we feed the politics of
Suspicion and Division there are real
alternatives to this we've seen in the
Ukraine scheme that Asylum Seekers and
refugees
can live within existing communities
such communities should receive prompt
and adequate government support it does
cost money but cheaper than exporting
our responsibilities are much cheaper if
the system is compassionate clear
efficient accurate and effective
we are clear that the UK cannot take
everyone
but it can make its decisions through a
system which balances effective accurate
and clear control with compassion and
dignity a system which is based in our
history and proper moral
responsibilities
we used to talk of no recourse to public
funds a system of segregation risks
creating a policy of no recourse to
public compassion
we should take heart from the
Magnificent public response to refugees
of recent years there are still in this
country profound reserves of kindness
and Goodwill to draw
so what can we do in the short medium
and long term
underpinned by these principles in the
short term combat Smugglers and prevent
small boats crossing the channel
to minimize irregular arrivals we need
to provide safe ways and legal ways for
people to get here and receive
assessment and wear appropriate
protection
approaches include expanding family
reunification models Community
sponsorship and humanitarian visas and
corridors from a far greater number of
countries
we cannot continue with the tenfold
increase in the number of people waiting
more than a year for an initial decision
an increase between 2010 and 2020.
the average processing time
for an asylum case is currently around
15 months it should be a maximum of six
in Germany in 2021
the average Asylum procedure took 6.6
months
despite a far higher Refugee and Asylum
Seeker population
nearly one-third of those who've been
waiting more than six months are made up
of Nationals from 10 countries that have
a successful application rate of between
75 and 99 percent
it is ridiculous and disgraceful that
people think Afghanistan and Syria are
having to wait so long when their
applications will most certainly be
granted
it is right that safe countries are
currently determined by statutory
instrument
then Parliament can democratically
scrutinize those decisions altering them
where needed on the views and needs of
the population
we need a triaging system to cut back
which distinguishes quickly between
People based on the likelihood that they
will be granted Asylum
it will speed up decision making and for
those who almost certainly would not be
granted Asylum it would allow them to be
removed almost immediately
that's not so far from our current
policy but in practice it's not
happening
the home office could do that
removing people whose claims are
unsuccessful can happen in a dignified
way there's been real success with
voluntary removals in the past when the
government collaborated with civil
society returns have been on a downward
trajectory however for a number of years
removals will only be Swift Just and
fair if the system is clear accurate and
not overwhelmed
in the meantime
we should also make one major change
which I propose which is that assignment
Seekers should not just be allowed to
work but expect it to work
in limited circumstances
except in limited circumstances where it
would clearly be inappropriate
this combines the right to fair and
dignified protection matched with a
responsibility to contribute to their
new Society in the common good
in the medium term
in the four seconds I've got left
um I suggest we suggest that
people smuggling like piracy should
become an international crime
and that the UK should take the lead in
The Struggle against people smuggling
forming an international body to track
it down and attack it everywhere it's
what we did in the 17th century against
piracy in the 19th century against slave
trading surely this is as serious
in the longer term
finally we need to update the 51 Refugee
convention
which is is hugely valuable in
maintaining the importance of protection
for all refugees but must be made fit
for the new challenges we face
a recent report by the Legato Institute
Institute lays out some areas of
ambiguity including the role of the safe
Third Country principle the
responsibility to report other countries
who are ousting many refugees guidance
on return and readmission and the
eligibility of people fleeing new
drivers of displacement such as climate
migrants this problem is going to get
worse my laws
Britain has shown Global Leadership in
1951 we can do so again we need more
ambition in our policies
time is not a luxury climate change and
conflict
risks driving migration for future
Generations at a rate we cannot imagine
today perhaps tenfold more
of course we don't have the answer on
this these benches but the Church of
England together with many others plays
a leading role in dealing with the
consequences of our present policy and
its chronic dysfunction and we have done
so for quite a little while
in a chapel in Canterbury Cathedral
there is an inscription several
centuries old that bears witness to the
protection given to French huguenotes
who fled persecution in the 17th and
18th centuries
the community needed a place to worship
and a chapel in the cathedral was
offered to them by a simple exchange of
one-page letters
they are still there
the French Protestant church of
Canterbury is there today next to the
plaque which Heralds and I quote the
Glorious Asylum which England has in all
times given to foreigners flying for
Refuge against oppression and tyranny my
lords this is our tradition it is our
history it is our pride let us make it
our future I beg to move
the question is that this motion be
agreed to
my lord it's a great honor to follow
um the most reverent primate and I must
start by commending him for his choice
of topic and giving us the opportunity
to debate immigration and Asylum today
um and also commend him for his
comprehensive opening speech and
particularly his acknowledgment towards
the end of the need to revisit the
refugee convention
my lords um during the passage of the
nationality and borders Bill earlier
this year
several peers Justified their opposition
by claiming that most voters who wanted
greater immigration controls did so on a
false understanding
basically that these voters could be
ignored because they weren't
sufficiently informed
now according to you gov's latest
tracker poll published on Monday this
week 56 of all UK adults believe that
the rate of immigration to the UK is too
high
in my remarks I want to focus on why
more than half of us who are
contributing to our economy and our
local communities take that view and our
demanding action
and let's be clear they are people of
all colors faiths and religions some
themselves will be immigrants or
children of immigrants and they deserve
to be heard and understood
what we've learned about the divisions
in our society exposed by recent
Democratic events helps us to understand
what unites this diverse group
they're likely to work hard do their
best for their family be good neighbors
and enjoy living and working in a place
to which they have a sense of belonging
instinctively they will share a
commitment to social norms standards of
behavior and common courtesies which
support good order and represent
fairness and the consideration of others
it's obvious stuff that costs nothing or
very little things like taking out turn
and not jumping cues being reliable and
keeping our words caring about the
general upkeep of public spaces or
dressing smartly when the place or
occasion deserves a demonstration of
respect
these are important shared standards
because they are acts of self-discipline
that demonstrate respect and help us
form bonds which cross boundaries and
build trust
they are standards that are neither
beneath anyone nor Beyond anyone
people expect those of us in positions
of authority in politics Business Media
or the church
to help protect and promote these common
standards by sharing them too
but what have we relegated our common
Bonds in favor of
something more exclusive
well also when did virtue signaling to
one another within the elite become more
important than keeping faith with the
values we all have in common regardless
of our status
we've allowed criminal gangs and
opportunists to weaponize our
differences and to endanger the lives of
economic migrants in the process
and if that's not bad enough at the same
time we're increasing the divisions in
our society by suggesting that the
Democratic wishes of the majority don't
matter
my lords that's why we need to get a
grip of illegal immigration
we shouldn't be surprised that people
become distressed by increased pressure
on local services and when it comes to
those who do unskilled work in
warehouses distribution centers or
factories we fail to understand that
what makes those jobs bearable alongside
decent pay and working conditions is
creating a sense of community through a
camaraderie Collective effort and
friendships
a working environment that's attractive
to people doing repetitive jobs is
difficult to create when no one cares if
the workforce can relate to each other
and Technology not human beings
determine operational standards and
whether someone is doing a good job
my lords no one expects or wants zero
immigration and people want to help and
support refugees fleeing war and
persecution
successful and effective immigration and
Asylum policy relies on as understanding
the valid concerns of the majority of
our citizens who are opposed to the
current rates of people entering the UK
the first step has to be implementing
tighter controls
high-minded pronouncements handwringing
and the free-for-all it's creating are
what is putting lives in danger not
doing everything we can to deter people
from illegally crossing the channel
I would support any further measure to
that end brought forward by the
government and I hope Sarah's
consideration is given to the
recommendations and the CPS report by
Nick Timothy and Carl Williams published
this week and I hope my Noble friend the
minister will comment on that when he
comes to wind up
my Lord
what I know is that dismissing people's
concerns fuels divisions and drives
distrust in the Democratic process
and if we are serious about building a
more prosperous and cohesive Society we
need to show we are proud to be living
alongside the great people of this
country who are what makes us successful
and whose good character is what
attracts talent and like-minded people
from all around the world yeah yeah
my lords
I'm pleased and very honored to make my
maiden speech today
I would like to thank your Lordships for
the kindness and support that I've
received since entering this house
I would also like to thank Lord Kennedy
of southwark and baroness Smith of
Basildon for introducing me to the house
and for their advice and guidance over
the past few weeks
I'm grateful as well for the advice and
guidance of all colleagues from across
the house
I've hugely appreciated the warm welcome
and answers to my many questions from
the doorkeepers and other staff
a particular thanks for the welcome and
assistance given to my parents and my
parents-in-law on the day of my
introduction I feel blessed that they
could attend along with my stepchildren
if this country is built on migration
then the same is true for my family my
husband is Norwegian and my interest in
politics was inspired by my Irish
grandfather who spent part of his
childhood living above a laundry on a
country estate his family in service
my grandfather Jack Campbell went on to
become a civil servant I did try to
follow in his footsteps but was rejected
for being too opinionated at my
interview
this rejection however led to me having
the most interesting life and career so
far and was arguably one of the best
things that ever happened to me
my lords I've been fortunate to work
with some incredible people and to study
live and work throughout the UK
my current role is Deputy math for fire
and resilience and I'm grateful for the
opportunity the mayor of London Sadiq
Khan gave me by appointing me to this
role
a role which saw me taking a lead in
London's response to covid
I owe a lot to those I've worked for and
the confidence they have shown in me
over my career
indeed I've worked out that I have well
over half a dozen former bosses in this
house
mainly for my time working for the labor
party but also from my time at the
health charity diabetes UK
this alone will make me mind my behavior
and my goal is to avoid faux pas and I
aim as we all do to make a difference
through my work here
at the moment however I am trying my
hardest to figure out the correct time
to stand where to walk and not walk and
where to sit and how to make sure I
don't get shouted at
my experience here so far reminds me of
my early days as a London assembly
member where everyone else seems to
understand the unwritten protocols and
the unspoken rules
thank you to all those who are helping
to guide me through these rules in
particular baroness Donahue and baroness
wheeler
I'm also grateful for the opportunity to
speak in this important debate
immigration is an issue I feel
passionately about and I agree strongly
with the sentiments so eloquently
expressed in the most reverent primate's
excellent speech
I declare an interest at this point as
chair of the London resilience forum
the London resilience Forum has over 200
member organizations
these are generally organized
Interceptor panels to ensure the voices
of all those organizations that may be
called upon to plan for or respond to an
emergency are heard
today's debate is particularly
appropriate in recognition of the work
of the Church of England in leading the
faith sector panel in London and the
work the church undertakes in similar
roles on lrs across the country
along with the voluntary sector
including both National and
community-based organizations Faith
organizations representing all faiths
provide the welcome those fleeing
conflict or Injustice deserve
they play a vital work in the role of
lrs in relation to force migration
local resilience forums over the past
few years have become in some ways the
go-to Partnerships of Last Resort often
picking up issues where government can't
identify another obvious way to deal
with a crisis
the lrf preparedness includes responding
to support colleagues from other
agencies and Partnerships such as a
regional strategic migration
Partnerships when Force migration does
not run as smoothly as it might
over recent years we've seen Force
migration increase with conflict
overseas we should be particularly proud
of how the British population stepped up
to welcome ukrainians to this country
there is much to learn and Ponder in the
context of this debate can I briefly
however refer to the Afghan relocations
and assistance policy or Arabic scheme
which was set up in April 2021
a number of those with local government
expertise have already described
the Admiral work carried out during this
period but also how numerous people
including families pregnant women and
children have been accommodated
sometimes for months and years in
overcrowded hotels
it is clear that the government could be
far better prepared in relation to
planning for the airlifts from Kabul
which took place in August 2021
can I refer instead to the role of the
London fire brigade my lords as you know
the London fire brigade has had some
very challenging press over recent weeks
and some of its problems in relation to
culture were debated by this house
yesterday
I am proud that the lfb is facing its
problems head on
what I would also say is that despite
its issues the lfb is the best type of
emergency service when called upon in a
crisis the fire brigade is made up of
doers the type of people who run towards
a problem rather than run away
so on the August bank holiday last year
when I was told there was a problem in
terms of basic items reaching immigrants
and a lack of drivers to deliver them I
picked up the phone to the fire brigade
to ask if they had the capacity to
deliver Essentials such as nappies and
sanitary towels to hotels housing recent
arrivals from Afghanistan and my lords
they sorted the vital deliveries within
hours
in conclusion I'd like to say it's been
an honor to be able to make my first
speech in your lordship's house in this
in this debate and on this important
subject I look forward to making future
contributions on this and other matters
um my Lord may I congratulate my Noble
friend for the excellent Maiden speaks
she brings with her a great little
experience of the thought we want to
hear more of both from the volunteer
sector and from local government and I'm
sure she'll make an outstanding
contribution to the Future debates I
also welcome the fact that she's chosen
this particular debate to make her Mark
and I hope she will contribute to many
of the discussions we're going to have
on Asylum and Refugee policy in the
future this is not the end of it
there'll be many many more many more
debates could I also say how delighted I
was when I learned that the most most
urban climate the Archbishop of the
country had chosen this subject of all
possible subjects from his debate this
year it's one we've all been talking
about
it's an issue that matters and it gives
us a chance to talk about many of the
things that many of the things that are
relevant and that indeed he has raised
in his excellent speech this morning
the the refugee issue is testing our
humanitarian principles to the ultimate
it will determine but in our response
what sort of country we are what sort of
country we want to be seen But
particularly how we value our fellow
human beings who've suffered greatly
from persecution from Wars and conflict
and I think we have to stand firmly
behind the principles established by the
Archbishop this morning my Lord says a
plaque off the center Lobby in in a
House of Commons which is a thank you by
the 10 000 children who came on Kindle
transport to this country in in 1938 and
1939 and it's a thank you for people as
one of them whose lives were saved by
the fact that this country took them in
and there are other people today whose
lives are being saved because we're
taking them in I believe in the
Archbishop of course we can't take
everybody but we should accept our
shared responsibility
and there is both a positive side to all
this and a negative side the positive
side is that there are some wonderful
people and groups and organizations
actually mentioned four of them the
faith groups have stood firmly by the
principle that we should treat our
fellow human beings decently all the
faiths Church of England Jews the
Muslims and so on they've all stood
firmly by the need for us to be
supportive of their fellow human beings
I find it exhilarating and and that they
are awarding to talk to schools
sometimes when I talk to schools about
what's going on I can hardly stop them
leaving school and rushing off to Cali
to help refugees which is not what the
teachers want but the fact is that in in
the jargon they get it they really do
get it more than most more than most
people and thirdly there are other ngos
who work with refugees as safe passage
is one but as a refugee counselor which
I'm a patron but the others as well care
for Kelly and they're doing an excellent
job in being supportive of their fellow
human beings and lastly the ones who
tend to be often forgotten in visiting
some of the refugee camps or what's left
them in Cali on the Greek Islands it is
the volunteers many from this country
but not exclusively so often young
people who are willing to devote a year
or two of their lives to help their
fellow human beings they don't get all
the accolades they don't get all the
praise I think they should because it is
a tremendous
sign of how young people are prepared to
work for the most vulnerable fellow
human beings in difficult and
uncomfortable and uncomfortable
circumstances my Lord in in looking at
the at the sound of the issue I have
clearly among others said that this must
not be the property of one political
party that we have to spread look look
across the board and what I found in the
course of the Amendments and some of the
arguments in which I got involved was
that even government ministers came up
to me and said keep going with your
Amendment even though the official
government policy was to deny their
Amendment and I thought that was pretty
exhilarating I said to volunteers but
you should be saying this to me never
mind keep going keep going with it with
your Amendment and I know for a fact
that it's quite senior levels
um
there was support for some of these
amendments the government is not
monolithic the government the government
is not saying we only have we only have
one one one one view on this and I'm
delighted but having having said having
said that I think it's important
in order that we can welcome vulnerable
people to our communities it's important
that senior people in government send
out the right signals because public
opinion needs to be won over to the
arguments that we heard from the
Archbishop this morning and public
opinion matters because it's public
opinion that has in the past
persuaded the government to concede to
one of the Amendments I was putting
forward because public opinion was
pretty forceful I remember walking down
the road in West London and somebody
shouted and normally when they shouted
politicians it's hostile but it wasn't
a voice said keep going with your
Amendment and I took the great deal of
comfort from that and and although I get
a few hostile emails and things the
number of supportive messages from the
public far outweighs the hostility and
now you know maybe that's not a that's
not a very good statistical sample but I
I do believe that one of our challenges
is to keep public opinion on on our side
and I remember at the time of the
amendment public opinion was won over at
the site of a Syrian boy Alan kurdy
drowned on the Mediterranean Beach and
public opinion responded to this very
positively and I think that helped to
sway the argument but we have voices the
other way and the Archbishop referred to
the use of the word Invaders my lords in
history Invaders have been the enemies
of this country and we should not regard
people who are coming here for safety as
as uh as the enemy could I just finish
maybe if you were about by two comments
I I was in it as a large refugee camp in
Jordan called Zachary
and that refugee camp is physically
better than many because he's got the
electricity sanitation and prefab
buildings but I was talking to a Syrian
boy
who just finished his education in the
camp and I said to him what now and he
said well I can't get a job in the camp
I can't get a job
outside the camp what hope is there for
me and I think one of our main
responsibilities is to give hope to our
vulnerable fellow human beings it is
hope that is important and could I
finally say as a as somebody who came as
a refugee this country has been pretty
terrific to me I value that and I know
that refugees coming today will also
value being able to live in this country
find safety get on with education get
work and become part of our local
communities that is surely the
aspiration we started from
I know my lost the noble Lord has been
valuable to this country as well
um I should say that I'm chair
um the house as Justice gnome Affairs
select committee but I'm speaking uh not
for the committee today but myself
though of course informed by the
committee's current work on family
migration
families and migration significant not
only to people struggling and it is can
be a great struggle but to to be with
family now but to those of us who owe
our presence in the UK to our families
decision to come here as the noble lady
has reminded us
sometimes as recently as the previous
generation many are in high places now
and a good thing too
that's in my mind when I hear the
increasingly exclusionary and unworkable
policies I hear them as rhetoric not
reason
when it's leadership calming of
suspicions that's needed the first time
I stood for election more than 40 years
ago someone said to me where will my
grandchildren live it's not a new issue
but the provision of housing education
range of services for the settled
Community should not be a matter for
competition with newcomers both groups
need them the house is is grateful to
the most reverent for articulating what
some of us struggle to express
the Home Secretary is reported as saying
we need a bill of responsibilities as
distinct from a Bill of Rights but
aren't both important
I'd hope that includes responsibility
too for instance and there are lots of
examples one could give employees of the
British Council and their families stuck
in Afghanistan I don't need to describe
their plight Those Who provided security
for our diplomats can the minister say
something about the numbers actually
assisted under the acrs and era and how
many are eligible for those schemes but
have not been able to take advantage of
them
I do in fact think there is a sort of
contract between those the UK welcomes
and this country so welcome is not the
right word for how much of the process
is working but maybe it's the company I
keep I've never met an asylum Seeker or
a refugee who is not so grateful and so
Keen to contribute to our society and so
frustrated by the rules which preclude
it
the irony is of course that skills and
talents which many refugees bring are
needed here and their characteristics
too would I have had the gumption to get
up and go or put my head in the sand
there are particular character traits
involved alongside the the external
imperative and these are traits which
employers welcome and we know that are
needed
my Lord slavery and trafficking are not
unrelated to Asylum seeking yesterday I
heard conscription
in Eritrea described as state slavery
not every slavery claim is false
is the government retreating from its
work on Modern slavery what do we read
into the delay in appointing a new
independent anti-slavery commissioner
is every Albanian to be disbelieved
who can be surprised that Albanian
children are going missing it's a
well-known pattern because traffickers
abusers are more trusted by victims
more than the UK authorities I
understand that 88 of Albanian women
have succeeded in their Asylum claim and
that is not an outlier of a figure
referred to the CPS publication of this
week endorsed by the Home Secretary
the Center's website page on the
publication refers to the views of
conservative switchers who voted
conservative in 2019 but have drifted
away that seems to be the audience
and importantly we must distinguish
Asylum Seekers and refugees from
immigrants immigrants who come here for
various uh reasons and who are by far
far the greater number
years ago I heard the term detained Fast
Track I thought that was benign Fast
Track Acceptance in 2015 the system was
declared unlawful primarily because this
is Lord Dyson in the court of appeal the
time limits are so tight as to make it
impossible for there to be a fair
hearing of appeals in a significant
number of cases are we heading for seek
Asylum detention Fast Track away without
assessment the new tier system means no
assessment at all
the government seems to focus on
excluding Asylum Seekers what we don't
hear about is what effort is going into
dealing with the Smugglers the criminals
as distinct from re-victionizing their
victims the criminals are able to tweak
their business model or move it to say
Rwanda if they're not prosecuted and
penalized
the motion refers to forced migration
and climate change is forcing it with
migrants so far
displaced within their own region people
will take avoiding action that's not
economic
migration and we'll be planning ahead
and so should the UK be with compassion
confidence and practical common sense so
we're left with the question in the
context of the current and anticipated
International situations what does the
government regard as the UK's fair share
my lords I wish we had longer for this
debate
my Lord I am grateful to the Lord
Archbishop of Canterbury for this
important debate and much of what he has
told us has resident Echoes In Sikh
teachings I'm also grateful for the
baroness twicross for her maiden speech
a moving Maiden speech and look forward
to the other Maiden speech speeches
particularly that of my friend and
fellow seek Lord sahota
in the past it was normal to look on
people in distant lands with suspicion
and fear people likely to harm us and
are obviously Superior way of life
John ogont in Shakespeare's record
Richard II
underlined this way of thinking when he
described Britain as a precious stone
set in a silver sea to goddess against
the Envy of less happy lands today the
internet television have brought distant
and supposedly lesser people into our
living rooms and we see and share their
sorrow as of people as far apart as
Ukraine and Afghanistan who have lost
family members and their very homes as a
result of conflict
today we live in a smaller
interdependent world the war in Ukraine
has its repercussions all over the world
with famine in Africa the kovid pandemic
while starting in China caused death and
suffering across the world the
challenges of climate change and global
warming threaten future generations and
can only be met by co-operation in
Universal action
a Christian hymn reminds us new
occasions teach new duties time makes
ancient good and good they must upward
still and onwards who would keep abreast
with truth
it is inevitable that people suffering
man-made conflict or natural disasters
will try to better themselves and move
to areas of Greater safety and
opportunity
sadly they are often met with irrational
hostility to foreigners rooted in the
mindset of the past
religious leaders have long been aware
that seeing others as blessed people
brings is it it brings a recipe for
conflict more than 300 years ago
the Sikh gurus looking at the bigotry
and conflict producing claims of
superiority in the India of the day
boldly declared that for peace and
Justice we must recognize that we are
all members of One indeed in
interdependent Human family
what was desirable 300 years ago is an
imperative today
despite those this those seeking asylum
in this country have seen are seen as
Alien Invaders by many including our
home secretary in a callous desire to
appeal to latent bigotry she even went
further in putting blame for the
insanitary conditions and overcrowding
at the Manson processing center on the
Asylum Seekers themselves
with the very same logic it could be
equally argued that patients are to
blame for delays in admission to
hospitals
we are not even in the top 10 countries
as we've heard that show generosity to
strangers per head of population
today they are chronic shortages of
Labor in hospitals Care Homes and
elsewhere while at the same time we are
trying to send refugees desperate for
work to places like Rwanda
my Lord in the prayers that begin our
daily settings we are urged to put aside
our prejudices and use Christian
teachings to underpin political decision
making
Deuteronomy reminds us to be kind to
strangers for you as strangers in the
land of Egypt
nematicus reminds us when a stranger
resides with you in your land you shall
not wrong him you shall love him as
yourself
these four-sighted teachings echoed in
Sikhism and other faiths on the very
opposite of today's harsh attitudes to
those seeking Asylum then her harm not
only those seeking Refuge but also as
standing in the rest of the world there
should be re-examined with urgency
my lords can I start by thanking
baroness tricross for her gracious
Maiden speech and for mentioning the
role of churches in local resilience
forums I'm also looking forward to
hearing the two Maiden speeches to come
the right to Reverend prelate the bishop
of Lester and I were formerly colleagues
when I was Bishop of Loughborough and I
look forward to working with him in this
house
I want to thank two my right Reverend
friend the Archbishop of Canterbury for
securing this timely and important
debate this past year alone we've seen
multiple developments of concern an
increase in forced migration due to
conflicts around the globe over a third
of Ukraine's population displaced by war
with Millions seeking Refuge beyond
their borders a record 40 000 plus
people making the precarious English
Channel Crossing we've also seen deeply
troubling conditions faced by people
once in the UK overcrowded processing
centers threats of deportation to Rwanda
and a lack of resettlement through the
Afghan citizens resettlement scheme
in the swirl of Revelations and
challenges it's easy to see swept Along
by the immediate looking for a quick fix
before the next issue comes along there
is of course real value in reacting
effectively in the moment particularly
from those meeting humanitarian need as
seen with the extraordinary response of
the British public to the homes for
Ukraine scheme
but there's also value in reflection on
the principles that guide such actions
and the system that they exist within
what is the purpose of our migration
system and who is it for
to Echo the words of the Archbishop at
the heart of the matter is the
recognition that every one of us is
created in the image of God with
intrinsic worth and dignity
scripture calls on us to feed the hungry
clothe the naked and welcome The
Stranger
in our contemporary context what does
welcome look like for those seeking
Refuge today
this is the very question that the wolf
institutes newly formed and independent
Commission on the integration of
refugees is exploring I declare my
interest as Vice chair of the commission
it's an honor to be involved under the
excellent chairmanship of the noble Lord
Carlisle as he will shortly outline in
Greater detail I'm sure we're seeking to
bring together a range of views and
experiences from our commissioners and
from others across the country those
with very different opinions and
approaches are agreed that the system is
broken and we've come together to move
towards a vision for better integration
of refugees as the good faith
partnership wrote in their report for
the commission published just last month
the stage is set for those with
practical ideas to tap into the widely
held desire from the British public to
integrate newcomers into their homes and
communities
I and many others believe one of those
key practical ideas is the provision of
housing good Refugee integration
requires good Housing Solutions again I
declare my interest as lead Bishop for
housing
I arrived in this country with my
parents at the age of 13 while the
Iranian Revolution gripped my homeland I
arrived as a refugee we were able to
build our lives here in large part
thanks to the housing provided us when
we arrived first in a theological
college and later in a vacant vicarage
we had a home again stability and safety
from which to build our lives again and
it's out of that that my own life has
grown
creating this rootedness remains a key
factor for successful Refugee
integration today
the report of the archbishop's
commission on housing church and
Community coming home concluded that
good housing should be sustainable safe
stable sociable and satisfying for many
refugees however this is not their
experience countless remain in
overcrowded temporary accommodation for
long periods in August 2021 over 20 000
Afghan citizens were evacuated by the
British military more than a year later
12 000 plus are still housed in hotels
costing 1.5 million a day this is both
dehumanizing and expensive
so how do we respond
part of the solution is meanwhile
housing the installation of demountable
sustainable high quality homes on
meanwhile use land this provides better
outcomes for refugees and improves use
of public funds
Bristol city council's project enabling
housing Innovation for inclusive growth
has been pioneering in taking this
solution forward
and we at the newly launched Church
housing Foundation are actively working
with government and others to find ways
to assist the provision of meanwhile
housing
additionally lifting the ban on the
right to work as the Archbishop has said
would have a transformative impact
enabling individuals to create more
security for themselves by putting to
use the skills that they have
indeed a ugov poll earlier this year
found that 81 of the public agree
my lords a high percentage of those who
apply for Asylum are granted permission
to stay
if these individuals are to have a
chance of settling well they must
discover a new sense of belonging and
belonging grows from a combination of
receiving good and dignified welcome for
example on how they're housed and in the
opportunity to contribute from the
earliest moment chiefly through the
right to work
and finally on a positive note I want to
recognize and praise the incredible work
going on in local churches and
communities across the country to
welcome the stranger including in the
diocese I serve Chelmsford as we strive
towards better Refugee integration in
principles and in practice I believe we
can also be encouraged by the many good
examples already around us
I congratulate the noble Lord the
Archbishop on introducing this Spate and
on the powerful way in which he did so
it is good to hear from the Bishops
benches
a statement of Christian principles
applied to the issues of the day rather
than just the normal
um
aspects of political debate
this issue raises very difficult
dilemmas for Christians
being a very inadequate Christian myself
I take up the archbishop's challenge
with trepidation to try and formulate
any principles for governing our policy
on Asylum and migration
and unlike the Archbishop not having
direct access to the mind of God I seek
those principles in the Bible
and I recall that our lord said that the
essence of Christianity is to love God
love our neighbor as ourselves and when
asked what who is our neighbor he gave
the parable of the Good Samaritan
and which a Samaritan helped to do
uh from which I deduce that uh our
neighbor is not just the person next
door to us not even necessarily a member
of our own Nation
it can be uh anyone and
our first the first principle I
therefore deduce is that their charity
begins at home
as a lot of my constituents used to tell
me it doesn't necessarily end at home
and I'm at one with the Archbishop about
that
second the Samaritan did what he
practically could
uh we may be called on to help anyone
that we practically can but we cannot
help everyone and again the Archbishop
recognized that and I think it's
important that we recognize that our
responsibilities are finite in this
respect respect
thirdly when the uh levite and the
Jewish priest reached their destination
I've no doubt they deplored the fact
that owing to years of austerity there
was insufficient spending on police and
the Health Service to prevent uh the
problem arising in the first place or to
treat the uh a person instead of leaving
it to the passing Samaritan
uh so my third principle is that though
we as politicians that work third
principally is actually that
to be a good subversion you have to give
at your own expense you have to give
care and it help and so on
we as politicians may have to take
decisions on behalf of others but in
doing so we should have consideration of
the impact we are having on other people
and not imagine that we are being
virtuous ourselves when we do good at
their expense so the first principle
charity begins at home in how we treat
people who have come to settle here when
I was a child the parish from it was a
time when Mass immigration was just
beginning to this country and the parish
from which I lived asked each family to
link up with a migrant family many of
whom were lonely isolated and at worst
facing hostility
uh my family was linked up with a
martian couple it was like for Murphy
couple who we would like to suffer uh
every few weeks and became good friends
and I think that was done by parishes
across South London and I would love to
hear from the Bishops who haven't yet
spoken what is being done today by the
churches to try and help integrate those
who are here in our society and to be
the Good Samaritans to our neighbors
from abroad
charity doesn't end at home and I pay
tribute to those tens of thousands of
people who opened their homes to
families fleeing the bombing in Ukraine
while their men folk remain behind to
fight for their country
uh but we shouldn't imagine
that we are sharing in uh being Good
Samaritans if we say well let's emulate
them let's throw open the doors of our
country to uh everybody because if we do
that we're doing good at others uh
people's expense
uh we are effectively saying that
migrants as well as be they legal or
illegal be they are Asylum Seekers or
otherwise will through the housing
benefit and social housing have access
to rented homes and to social homes we
of course have all got our own home so
we won't be affected uh and uh therefore
more young people will have to wait at
home longer
uh or living cramped bed sitters for
longer because of what we may think as
legislators but we are doing generously
but not to take into account the impact
on others
uh
now the principal our neighbor can be
anyone but it can't be everyone yet
millions of people want to come here if
we look at the impact the Green Card
system the American has us operate when
they make available 30 000 uh visas to
the US to certain countries and say
anyone can apply it there'll just be a
ballot nine percent of the population of
Albania heard about that and applied
when it was offered to them eleven
percent of the Armenian population
applied when it was offered to them 14 I
think of the Liberian population applied
when it was offered to them and these
are only the people who hear and get and
respond the potential number of people
who would like to come to America or
Europe if we uh opened these so-called
direct routes would be enormous
and are we going to say to people who
apply at an embassy or some place abroad
that they will have the same legal
rights the same opportunity to appeal
and uh have judicial review if their
things are turned down if so potentially
millions of people would be joining the
queue it wouldn't shorten it it would
lengthen it so we have to restrict and
we have to prioritize
and I submit uh to Noble Lords that the
priority should not be the boat people
they're not coming from Basra or Somalia
or Eritrea by boat they're coming from
France and Belgium and Germany
and why are they coming here rather than
staying there those safe countries
because it's three or four times as
likely to be they're four times as
likely to be rejected and France in its
last year before the pandemic forcibly
uh repatriated 34 000 people
here I found some strange double
standards applied there are no
criticisms of France for being much
stricter than us
or for us for being much laxer than them
but one or the other must be the case
uh I'm coming to an end but if it is
morally and legally right for the French
to try and prevent people leaving their
Shores a morally and legally right for
us to pay and support the French in
trying to stop people leaving their
Shores surely it should be morally and
legally right for us to return them and
if they can't be returned it is
reasonable to say let us try and deter
them by saying if you come here you will
go to Rwanda but you always have the
opportunity of staying in France
I submit that uh you do not always
consider these opportunities well Lords
we've been particularly generous with
the timings could I remind Noble laws
that it is an advisory back then
speaking time of six minutes
uh my lords I'm pleased and honored to
make my maiden speech today
having had the honor of joining your
lordship's house my Noble Lords from all
sides of the house have given me the
warmest welcome for which I am most
grateful
I would like to thank the staff and the
doorkeepers of the house for helping me
in and out without them I don't know
where I would be probably lost in here
I would like to thank my two supporters
Lord Kennedy and Lord groeped I'd like
to thank the most Revenant primate
Archbishop of Canterbury for bringing
this important debate to this house I
would also like to begin personally
thanking the Archbishop for going to
amritsari in 1919 to pay his respect to
the victims of the jallianwala bagh
massacre on their 100th anniversary that
was the same year I made a documentary
on the same subject my Lord when I
arrived in UK in 1966 to join my father
for a few months later England won the
World Cup
since so I sincerely hope that my
elevation will have a similar effect
my family background is one of those
typical Sikh family
my uncle served in the British Indian
British Army in Burma during the second
world war under the command of Lord
mountbatten my grandfather his brother
my maternal grandfather all served in
the in the British Indian army in the
first world war and I sometimes wondered
what they will make of the fact that
their grandson is now a proud member of
your lordship's house
my uncle Chan Singh was the first
politician in in our family and during
the British Raj in his in India he was a
member of the movement which wanted the
Britain to quit India and when I told
him that I was going into politics and
he gave me a one line of advice that of
Guru Gobind Singh never be afraid of
doing the righteous thing
my father-in-law also dipped his toe in
a local politics in India and was
locally known as comrade Tara Singh also
I would like to thank my two cousins Dr
pritam sahota and fakir sahota for never
and for for their never-ending advice
and encouragement my lords it has been a
long and arduous Journey for me and my
family coming to this country from
1957 to this day
this is a country of which we are
immensely proud of and played a full
part
I said arduous Journey because in that
time
we had to face like countless other
economic migrant families the slings and
the arrows of soy of racial
discrimination such as substandard and
overcrowded accommodation dirty and
heavy work lack of health and safety
protection at work
and once my father was thrown out of the
pub for not speaking English
returning to the substance of the debate
my lords the present policy on Asylum
and refugees leaves a great deal to
desire
it is a slow and cumbersome
people are left in a limbo for years
deprived of their dignity and basic
human rights
in preparation for this debate last
Friday I visited refugees and Migrant
Center in Wolverhampton
where thousands of people come through
their doors seeking all kinds of help on
immigration citizenship
resettlement housing health and
well-being employment education passport
and so on and so forth I'm grateful to
the staff there for giving me their
valuable time and advice at this very
moment thousands of people are awaiting
decision on their Asylum applications
system is clearly broken and is bursting
at the seams my lords there are many
problems refugees faces while waiting
for the application to be processed
unable to settle down not knowing when
they may be when they when not knowing
when they may be uprooted
they are often taken advantage of by the
unscrupulous employers who pay them next
to nothing never mind the minimum wage
private landlords who often charge High
premium to rent out a room or a house
many are forced to work in a sex
industry to make ends meet many women
face domestic violence as a result of
being taken advantage of by the
Predators the stress of waiting for
their cases to be dissolved takes a
severe toll on their health and
well-being their children struggle at
school as they are unable to settle down
they are forced to beg and use food
banks to survive so there is a cost to
the police to the National Health
Service to the school and to the housing
sector all I ask the government is to
invest in a proper Asylum system more
and treat people who are fleeing tyranny
and prosecution in their own country
with dignity and compassion
my lords
when the founder of the Sikh religion
Guru nanak Dev ji was a young man his
father gave him some money to start a
business and instead of investing in a
business he spent the money on feeding
the hungry and destitute and when he was
asked why he has done this his reply was
this was the best deal I could find on a
market so my loads we too must strive to
find the best deal on the market for our
fellow human beings thank you
my lords what a privilege to follow that
the prodigious amounts and the breadth
of work that my new Noble friend has
done in his community but his
communities
is extraordinary
the energy that he's invested in making
life better for people across the
Spectrum with a special emphasis perhaps
on uh Sikh and Punjabi communities too
he's written a book of poetry and
Punjabi and as a lover of poetry I just
wish that I could now speak it I shall
sit with it with my Noble friend and
expect some explanations
he has spent his time cheering up so
many people
I last officiated
um at an event for a Shropshire lad
with the funeral of the late Lord Murray
of Epping forest and Telford and I
quoted then as I quote now although the
energy with which that speech has been
made makes it very clear that this is
not a funeral
I've said then you will keep from shame
in London streets the Shropshire name
on banks of Thames they must not say
seven breeds worse men than they
a force of Nature and part of what I
hope will be a leveling up
moment in the life of this house I'm
most grateful
as indeed I am to the most reverent
Prelude
the Archbishop
the first time in a long time I've
wanted to stand up and cheer
although that would have been against
all propriety in this house
because he has said so much that all of
us might have or many of us would have
wanted to say
perhaps an interest I should declare is
that I'm a member of the delegation from
the British Parliament to the Council of
Europe and I sit on its migration
committee I was there two days ago in
Paris considering a whole host of things
related to and consequent upon
the problems being faced not just in
this country but across our continent
and indeed around the world
I've heard from most Reverend Prelude
and indeed from others
a question about a possible updating or
modification of the 1951 convention
I was asked by the migration committee
to compose a report for the 70th
anniversary of the convention which was
approved by the Parliamentary assembly
of the Council of Europe just a year ago
and I will certainly be taking back to
the migration committee a proper
expression of the need it would have to
be an international lead
um to look again at the convention to
see what modifications are appropriate
in the present moment
but I have to say that for the moment
the 1951 convention is embedded in our
law
it is the law we must obey
we've had discussions about this in the
nationality and borders act as it moves
through this house and a great amount of
dismay was expressed at our apparent
Readiness to depart from our legal
obligations
that's the most worrying thing Noble and
learned Lords expressed their views
forcibly on this matter
um I in my work for the report I
prepared worked with unhcr Offices here
in London and in Strasbourg and in
Geneva and all of them can give well
have given to the British government a
very clear and Lucid understanding of
the law that would have taken into
consideration even what I'd have to
declare the extraordinary views of the
noble Lord Lord Lily that he expressed
after his time was up a moment ago
so it is the law
we must obey it we can modify it
the call by the the most reverent
prelude for international consensus
around this and other matters this is
the moment perhaps for that
at the heart of the convention lie three
principles
non-reformal
non-discrimination and non-penalization
those are cardinal elements in the way
the war the the convention is spelled
out and an examination of current
British practice measured against those
Cardinal elements
would well should we say raise questions
of an inordinate nature in our minds and
force us to look again at our moral
position against the law under which we
sit in a country that Prides itself on
the rule of law
my lords in the uh
meeting I was at two days ago in Paris
statistics that are not the usual ones
came my way from a high official of the
International Red Cross who spoke to our
meeting
she told us about the numbers of people
who have died who were who are missing
registered missing
only 13 of those registered missing in
the their attempt to find Refuge
somewhere 13 are ever found and
forensically identified
that is 87 never are
and although it's not my custom to read
parts of a report this paragraph a
chilling one is the one which I want to
conclude my remarks in this debate
these alarming numbers are only the tip
of a tragic Iceberg and many more
migrants are likely to have lost their
life or become untraceable
their families and friends typically do
not have any sign of life or death of
their loved ones
Anonymous dead migrants are washed
ashore in Europe and the southern
Mediterranean Sea or are found in
forests and cities and even lorries
requiring forensic analyzes and the
transfer of corpses for their burial
14 in the English Channel
25
271 in the Mediterranean Sea
should we not be worried and should this
debate not apply the greatest possible
pressure as far as we are concerned
to obtain the highest possible standards
I'm down
please make it six minutes thank you
Lord can I say what a privilege it is to
have the opportunity to take part in
this debate but also to follow my my my
my my Welsh Methodist Minister Leslie
Griffis we're introduced on the same day
quite a few years ago now and it's
delighted that way both of us are able
to take part in this debate I would ask
the government is it satisfied with the
process that Asylum Seekers have to go
through to achieve their status
this past September there were 127
000 Asylum applications waiting to be
dealt with
some awaiting a considerable time
decision takers doing their very best
but clearly the whole Recruitment and
training of decision takers need to be
with standard that inspires confidence
when a hundred thousand negative
immigration decisions
were rejected and reversed in the past
five years clearly the present system
does not Empire Inspire confidence
not to end the stuff who see their
original decisions rejected 50 percent
of the time
in the unnecessary anxiety to so many
applicants with often very very serious
and sad consequences
when the millions of pounds in
unnecessary expense
because of these reversals because of
the Appeals
but when an application must be
reconsidered that accounts as unless
it's expense
the unnecessary delays leads to
governments acting harshly and the UK's
reputation is smeared
now there are steps that can be taken in
a thorough going overhaul of the home
office and its immigration
responsibilities are absolutely crying
out crying out for for for
uh uh
um research
now the organization humanitarians
together is preparing a humanitarian
Manifesto which hopefully will propose
changes thank you that can be accepted
by all parties in this Parliament
foreign
primate for his annual debate Britain's
Asylum and Refugee policies is a timely
and indeed a necessary one and I'd like
to begin by thanking the most reverent
primate and his colleagues on the
Bishops bench and more widely also for
the contributions they have made to the
National debate on these issues for
injecting a tone of humanity and of
respect for Britain's International
obligations into a discussion which
frequently lacks either of those two
qualities
why is it necessary to debate because
however discordant the views expressed
on this subject are and they are
on one thing everyone seems to be in
agreement namely that our present
policies for dealing with Asylum Seekers
and refugees are defective and are not
working
so we really do need an overall rethink
of our policies not just a desperate
attempt to patch them up or to remedy
one or other defect which is highlighted
by the daily mails in Daily Mail in
screeching headlines and any rethought
policy needs to be consistent and
coherent if we are not simply to emulate
the Little Dutch boy plugging holes in
the dike with his fingers in that
category of desperate remedies the
government's aim of flying Asylum
Seekers off to Rwanda or to any other
developing country ready to have their
palms crossed with silver ranks high
indeed the legality of the policies
before the courts so I will not comment
on that aspect but it does not seem to
be acting as a deterrent to Asylum
Seekers as its protagonists claimed it
would
and the accounting officer at the home
office cannot certify value for money so
the sooner it's dropped the better
in the same category comes our adamant
refusal to allow Asylum Seekers even
those waiting for several years to have
their claims dealt with to take legal
employment other European countries
permit Asylum Seekers to work after six
months why can't we do so
and thus both reduce the mental and
physical stress put on the refugees and
their families and save ourselves some
taxpayers money so much for the
negatives of our present policies here
are some positive suggestions first we
surely must cut the ever-lengthening
delays in processing Asylum claims the
government seems to realize this but are
they taking effective action to speed up
the process
then we really do need to thrash out
with our Continental European partners
and not just the French a whole range of
policies designed to put the human
traffickers out of business and behind
bars where they deserve to be that means
more cooperation with the Oracle and
Euro just and a better more trusting
overall relationship with EU in its
member states just telling them to get a
grip is not going to achieve that
thirdly we need to give serious
consideration to opening up ways in
which claims for Asylum can be submitted
outside our borders and then processed
expeditiously that could be one of the
ways of reducing the temptation of
taking the perilous route by dinghy
across the channel
now all those measures are fully
consistent with our International
obligations which some of the
government's policies are not brushing
off the views to that effect of the UN
High Commission of refugees whose job it
is to oversee implementation of the
refugee convention and saying that we
think otherwise is simply Alice's red
Queen's response of it's so because I
say it so
and it's not consistent with asserting
that we are strong supporters of the
rules-based international order an
assertion which ministers stand at the
dispatch box and repeat several times
every week
I do sometimes wonder whether those who
Champion more restrictive and inhumane
policies have any understanding of our
country's record down the centuries in
welcoming Huguenot refugees from France
Jewish refugees from Russia and Eastern
Europe and from Nazi Germany Asian
refugees from East Africa did we benefit
from that or were we harmed by it well
the answer is evident just look around
this chamber look around the Chamber Of
The Other Place look around the cabinet
table and you will see the answer it's
surely time to apply the same values we
did earlier in our history when it comes
to treating today's Asylum Seekers
it's a very great pleasure to follow the
noble Lord Henry I have
always admired him but I didn't think
I'd ever agreed with everything he has
said and until today I agree with most
things he said today I endorse
everything and thank him for his very
vigorous speech and he's also a great
pleasure to be able to say a brief word
of thanks to the two Maiden speakers
and to look forward to the third the uh
the right Reverend the bishop of
Leicester
singularly appropriate that the
Archbishop should have chosen this
subject for this debate today
we are in Advent
approaching the season of Christmas
and some of our thoughts
even prompted by some of our Christmas
cards
will make us think of the flight into
Egypt
the most famous Refugee family in
history
and my lords what lord hanager said
about refugees coming to our country was
so true
they enriched our society
I myself benefited from a German Jewish
Refugee who was a neighbor of ours when
I was a Schoolboy
and who lectured in English literature
and who gave me
my passionate love of Shakespeare which
I retained to this day
he was married to a Spanish Refugee who
had fled from Franco's Spain
it's only a few weeks my Lord since In
This Very chamber
Lord Pollock puppet I'm sorry Lord Papa
introduced the debate
to Mark the 50th anniversary of the
coming of the Uganda Asians
they too have enriched our society
and of course if one does go further
back and one thinks of Canterbury and of
spittle fields and the Weavers
and the huguenots who numbered among
then the greatest silversmiths
of the 18th century Paul delamere
quarter
there's a name to conjure with
my lords we have to be
very mindful
of our enriched past
when we look at the present
I'm very proud of the way that our
country has responded
to the bestiality in Ukraine
and those families who've taken in
Ukrainian families
I'm very proud of the fact that we are
giving Refuge
to
people from Hong Kong
because of the abrogation of an
international treaty
by China
but treaty they signed with us
which itself should underline the
importance of our always honoring our
International treaties and commitments
but my notes I wanted to make one or two
practical suggestions as did the
Archbishop
and I very much agreed with what he said
about the traffickers of course
and Lord Hane echoed that a moment or
two ago
they should indeed be rounded up as
vigorously as we can possibly round them
up they can now be imprisoned for life
and that's very right and proper
and we should deal with them
but my lords we should also as Lord Hane
touched on we should also process
applications not only more quickly
but outside this country
and I put to my Noble friend a
suggestion only a week or so ago in this
house when we were at question time
and said to him can we not get together
with our friends in France in France in
spite of what my able friend Lord Lilly
says has received many refugees in the
Archbishop gave the figures when he made
his speech but can we go not get
together with our neighbors and friends
and have
build a real large hostel near Canada
Spartan if you like but clean
and decent
were these people can live relatively
comfortable lives and where their
applications can be processed by British
Customs uh British officials
because that would be a sensible
practical thing to do and it would help
to cut down these Dreadful cross-channel
Journeys
from which a number of people have
perished and of course we have the
number given a little while ago of the
25 000 in the Mediterranean
my lords we are dealing with human
beings
made in the likeness of God
human beings who are every have every
right to expect the dignity to be
respected and if they are genuine and of
course some of them are not
and they deserve punishment if they are
genuine
be given all the help that it is
practical to give
my lords I'm grateful to the archbishops
and I'm sure we all for the manner in
which he introduced this very important
debate
and let's hope that it leads to some
action if not this day at least tomorrow
declare my interests as as a member of
the noble lady baroness hamway's Justice
and home Affairs committee and also as a
long time supporter of the wonderful
charity Refugee Tales
um it's a pleasure as always to follow
the noble Lord Lord cormack and and also
um to Mark the end of my Noble friend
Lord dubs 90th birthday week this way
um my thanks like everyone else and to
um the most Reverend primate
uh the Lord Archbishop of Canterbury for
convening this timely debate on the eve
of Human Rights Day
I congratulate uh
my Noble friends
to maidens in labor if that's not a
contradiction in terms on their on their
wonderful
um contrasting um Maiden speeches and I
look forward to the
um to the maiden speech of the uh right
uh uh the bishop but get all my Bishops
mixed up the bishop of Leicester to um
to follow in a in a moment
um so unlike the noble Lord Cormac
actually I I also think it's apt I
always think it's apt that human rights
day is so close to Christmas
for the reasons he gave because
Christmas is a time when so many people
all over the world celebrate the birth
of a very special Refugee child but I
think it is worth remembering why we do
why we do celebrate um Human Rights Day
um Noble Lords will remember that it was
in October 1942 that then prime minister
Winston Churchill famously wrote to the
predecessor of um of our present
Archbishop
um in the following terms
the systematic cruelties to which the
Jewish people men women and children
have been exposed on the under the Nazi
regime are amongst the most terrible
events of history and place an indelible
stain upon all who perpetrate and
instigate them
free men and women denounce these vile
crimes
and when this world struggle ends
with the enthronement of Human Rights
racial persecution will be ended
inspirational if perhaps um optimistic
as it as it turned out
but remembering the failure
there was some failure of allied powers
to give adequate passage and protection
to those desperate to flee the Nazis my
lords I'll I'll remind them Lords that
Albert Einstein was denied Asylum here
and had to go to the United States for
it
um but some this failure to give
adequate pathogen protection even after
kristallnacht in 1938 heralded a policy
of systematic genocide
Refugee protection is therefore perhaps
the most poignant Paradigm of post-war
human rights
given the emerging understanding of the
sheer horror of the pre-war and War
years it's unsurprising that the refugee
convention should have been one of the
earliest priorities post-war
International legal architecture it
brings detail and binding effect
to supplement the right to Asylum in
article 14 of the universal declaration
came into force in 1954 and has been
amended only once
in 1967 protocol removed the original
limitation of protection to those
fleeing events before 1951 in Europe
so the subsequent protection was always
intended to be worldwide and permanent
and we've heard how the convention
defines a refugee as someone with a
well-founded fear of persecution for
reasons race religion nationality
membership of a social group or
political opinion who is therefore
unable or unwilling to return to their
country origin and as we heard from my
mobile friend Lord Griffith Barry Port
it's built on three principles
non-discrimination non-penalization and
non-reformal non-return
so the protection should be applied
without discrimination on the basis of
race religion or country of origin
but also as international law has
developed over time on other prohibited
grounds such as sex age disability
sexuality and so on
it recognizes my lords that the most
desperate genuine refugees may have no
choice but to flee as from the Nazis via
illegal means
using false papers and identities and
clandestine transport across borders in
breach of ordinary immigration controls
of Nations
so the convention prohibits penalizing
them for example by criminal offenses
relating to their seeking Asylum or by
way of arbitrate attention
Ally the convention absolutely prohibits
their return or expulsion
to places where their lives or freedoms
would be in peril
it further provides for minimum
standards for the treatment of refugees
they should have access to courts
primary education papers including
travel documents and the UN High
Commissioner is charged with supervising
the operation of the convention which
signatory states undertake to cooperate
with my Lord's a refugee convention is a
vital part of Human Rights Machinery in
providing at least a basic safety net
when individual nation states who
granted by The Lion's Share of
responsibility the guaranteeing rights
and freedoms failing that Duty
to undermine it in thought word and deed
as so many governments have done
so much of our still young century
is to forget or ignore the worst
atrocities of the last one
my Lord it is a privilege to be making
my maiden speech in this most important
debate and I'm grateful to my most
Reverend friendly Archbishop of
Canterbury for putting forward this
motion
I'm also grateful to Noble Lords for
their welcome today and I look forward
to learning from and working with you in
the service of his Majesty's government
and our great nation
and as one of my relatives was actually
the first ever manager of the English
football team I want to Echo the noble
Lord sahota in his hope that his and my
elevation may lead to success as in
1966.
as Bishop of Leicester I have the honor
of serving a city which has been made by
migration including those seeking Asylum
among them Asian refugees expelled from
Uganda 50 years ago Somalian refugees
fleeing the Civil War in the 1990s
socially culturally and economically
Lester has benefited phenomenally from
the talents hard work and Rich Heritage
of Migrant communities
but I don't wish to speak of migrants as
I believe we often do as other a group
distinct from ourselves
for I too am a migrant I was born in
Indonesia I spent my early years growing
up there I also benefited from several
years working with my wife in Guinea in
West Africa and here in the UK I've
moved between Sheffield Gloucester and
Leicester
and most fundamentally I belong to a
spiritual tradition which sees all those
who follow Jesus as pilgrims in this
foreign land as the famous hymn goes
which is to say that at many points in
my life I have been dependents on the
hospitality of others
dependent on them seeing me as kin as a
fellow human a friend not a foe
dependence also on the generosity of
strangers friends and ultimately the
graciousness of Gods
indeed since entering this house I've
depended on the advice patience and
thoughtfulness of my sponsors fellow
Lord spiritual members of this house the
officials and staff here and my Diocesan
colleagues I'm very grateful to them all
like any newcomer I have needed
shepherding into unfamiliar spaces and
ways of doing things
yet I fear that as a nation we offer
little of that welcome guidance and
orientation to refugees and Asylum
Seekers our fellow men and women who
have suffered trauma Terror abuse and
hardship on their Journey
initially we have a number of hotels
accommodating Asylum Seekers they may
have a roof over their heads but they
are not given even the most basic of uh
means of living as human beings the
freedom to make even small decisions
like what's to eat
the Independence that comes from having
enough money to buy Essentials for
oneself
the stable connections to a community
which offer a sense of belonging and
supports
at the drop of a house they can find
themselves relocated to another part of
the UK or deported forcibly returning
from a plate to a place they were so
desperate to leave
the noble Lord Lily asked for examples
of what the church is doing to support
such people and I want to assure you
that in Leicester there are those from
our churches who visit people in these
hotels provide clothing and food and in
one recent events that I know of gave a
cultural evening for Kurdish women with
food and dancing an opportunity to learn
from their culture even as they learn
from Arts
however in denying refugees and Asylum
Seekers their agency their dignity and
their need for creativity and Community
it is not only them we dehumanize
it is ourselves as well
I believe that Christ showed us that
true humanity is showing love over fear
so when we are possessed by fear of the
other fear of losing control over our
borders fear of what refugees show us of
the fragility of human structures and
ways of life we are lesser versions of
ourselves
of course recognizing our kinship with
Asylum Seekers and refugees does not
decide the political questions around
immigration
questions of integration and how to live
well together must be wrestled with
but those questions we must grapple with
regardless and we must do so with
sincerity and integrity
the unrest which Lester experienced in
September of this year demonstrates why
we need robust strategies which support
immigration integration
on both sides of the chamber and in both
houses we can all agree that we want a
country where people of all backgrounds
and beliefs can work live and learn
together enriched by our diversity
but we cannot be naive in assuming that
strong cohesive communities occur by
default
integration requires efforts from all
government departments not just the home
office
dcms with its new Online safety bill for
example can help limit the sort of
disinformation which fueled the disorder
in Leicester
the foreign and Commonwealth office can
take seriously how political Affairs in
other countries have Ripple effects here
in the UK
and the department for Education can
ensure that all children leave schools
with a strong understanding of and
respect for the various Faith Traditions
present in the UK
we cannot offer true Refuge if we do not
have a collective home to welcome people
into
my kindness by compassion the
recognition of someone's inherent
dignity and work
we can make anywhere feel like home
it is how the UK and Leicester have come
to be home for me and how I hope this
house will also come to be somewhere I
am familiar with
you so I'm delighted to follow the
Wright brothers Bishop of Leicester in
whose diocese I live and worship
um he made an excellent speech if I
might say so I've never heard him give a
sermon perhaps we can put that right for
somebody dick
um and um I agreed with quite a lot of
they said surprisingly
um
I regard his predecessor Tim Stevens as
a friend I hope Tim Stevens regarded me
as a friend as well
um
my view as a still loyal member of the
Church of England
and on Sunday I heard from David heplway
who you might know an excellent sermon
in Stamford Haven uh the origins of the
Christmas stocking how many people here
know the origins person's talking I
didn't until then I'm 71.
um but as a as a my view is that we need
a spiritual and moral Dimension to
politics and to government policy
and into legislation it's a minority
view but I therefore
support having a fiscal bench in the
House of Lords and will continue to use
it and indeed having an established
church so I welcome the right room
private chair
um his predecessor guy Vernon Smith
married my mother in Cosby twice
unfortunately because her first husband
is on War Memorial
now I hope to see more of him here I
hope to see more of him in Leicester
may I also take this opportunity to
applaud the two serving archbishops for
their quite excellent sermons both the
Platinum Jubilee service and Her
Majesty's funeral
there were occasions which showed the
church
absolutely at its best
and frankly rising to occasion so may I
thank them for that so I speak as a
member of the Church of England
a Christian but not worthy to preach I
can assure you of that and my faith is A
Private Matter
and I but I wish to give at least one
View today of A View From the queues
it's not my intention to attack either
the church and all the Bishops so I
shall ask questions but it's perhaps the
most relevant credit might have time to
address the end I agree by the way with
a lot that he said
um in April though he said quote the
standard by which we must treat those
seeking Asylum is love thy neighbor as
thyself agree
which brings me to the question that
prompted that most powerful parable of
the Good Samaritan who is Thy Neighbor
on this occasion who is a refugee
refugees typically return when it's safe
to do so like the Holy Family to which
neighbor Lord Cormac addressed uh
mentioned I absolutely accept
uh the direction we have to show
compassion and that lesson in Matthew 25
but there is huge pressure on our
borders on our services on our
infrastructures and that is caused by
people who understandably
want a better life they want to come to
Britain it's a fantastic country
although to hear some here in the
chamber you think it was most awful
placing you can't think why they'd want
to come
but may I focus particularly on small
boats in the channel which is of course
very close to the
most Reverend predates um dioces of
Canterbury
is smuggling by criminal gangs we've
heard of and nearly half in the last
five months that have come across the
channel have come from Albania via
France now Albania is a safe country I'm
not sure about France although people go
to France on holiday and I have been and
indeed to Italy Greece and Germany
um
but people are being are people being
persecuted either in Albania or in
France
they come here because we welcome them
we give them accommodation we give them
benefits Etc we are frankly extremely
generous which is why they don't want to
stay in France who are less generous the
albanians are instructed by the people
Smugglers to say they're victims of
trafficking against the human
trafficking Bill those from the Middle
East or from countries that Outlaw
homosexuality and to say their apostates
or their gay so they can't be sent back
anybody can incredibly do so even if he
he or she is 25 years old says their
children
we are being taken I fear as fools
largely by Smugglers who know their
Market if I put it that way
just as Imad al-swillman
took the clergy at Liverpool Cathedral
for naive Falls when he said he was
converted to Christianity it was
confirmed having been supported by
Asylum link then he took a bomb in a
taxi to blow up the Remembrance Day
service in Liverpool Cathedral so let's
be sensible please not naive
my Lord's one reason people want to come
here is our history and our culture
which my Noble friend
a baron is still referred to the welcome
we gave Jewish refugees from the pogroms
in Poland and Russia in the late 19th
century or from Germany in the 20th
century
I'm proud of that very proud of that but
we are as a result literally changing
the way our Country carries on and its
culture through Mass migration
now there is a stress from a few many
people like those I've mentioned who do
not want do not share our values are
small ill liberal attitudes let's not
pretend everybody does
so let me ask some questions on culture
for instance
I missed this but did the church or
Bishops Lobby to continue having daily
acts of worship in schools you may think
that's unimportant but
Apache Church schools fewer State
schools very few State schools now have
a daily uh Christian service in him and
the most basic lost culture of course is
that
people don't know this glorious hymns
and now and matches they'll swing sing
Sweet Caroline rather than abide with me
which you may not think is important but
is a is a pointer
and what is the Church of England
planning to do to reverse the decline in
Christian belief Bishops will be
irrelevant
if nobody believes in Christianity I
think the worst news this month has been
the fact that there's been a huge
decline in those who call themselves
Christian
and that of course relates to education
now does the most Reverend Archbishop
believe that the church is
institutionally racist because if it is
I don't want anything to do with it but
we hear Bishops do say that
um my lords
there's another question why was Calvin
Robinson kicked out as an ordinary now I
don't know him he may be very unsusable
but but his story is coming out it's not
good now closer to home as an
illustration and not to embarrass the
right Reverend premature I follow I live
in a group of 11 parishes we've had no
resident priest for three and a half
years
so I traveled over 10 miles on Sunday
burning fossil fuel but the two Bishops
in Leicester where the population of the
city is now apparently only 32 Christian
um I note that the people I see in
church sorry I know that the
I'm going to sit down 100 years ago
every Parish
a good time for me to remind
um 100 years ago every Parish had a
resident priest and no Bishops because
darcis was only founded founded in 20 uh
2019-27. now I will sit down but I have
to say
as a loyal member of the Church of
England
I want to see that the
I frankly hope that the Archbishop might
commend the people
and the governments of this country
is fought nationally and in Kent for the
generosity in Hospitality that we have
shown
over the last half century to the over
10 million people that have settled here
who have every one of them has been a
stranger in this land
my Lord so I thank the most Reverend
primer for initiating this debate and
above all for the characteristically
profound ethical Foundation of his
speech
I also command three truly promising
Maiden speeches and I look forward to
hearing more from all of their Lordships
my lords as the right Reverend prelate
the bishop of Chelmsford has said I
happen to have agreed to chair an
independent Commission on the
integration of refugees in my view a
core necessity integration of the
subject under debate
convened and funded by the wolf
Institute which is based in Cambridge
the commission has more than 20
Commissioners from many disciplines some
of whom have real lived experience of
Life as a refugee
I thank the right Reverend prelate the
bishop of Chelmsford and two other Noble
Lords who kindly consented to be on my
commission namely baroness Hale and
baroness neuberger just telling your
Lordships those names confirms the
promise of a thoroughly penetrating
debate as well as a chilling chairing
challenge
our purpose is to bring together
different experiences opposing views to
build consensus on this sometimes
contentious political issue ours is
neither a campaigning commission nor
politically partisan indeed in many ways
it is simply a corollary to the most
reverent primates debate today
integration means different things to
different people it's a two-way process
for new and existing communities
respectively the nature and outcome of
integration is multifaceted British
values and culture are diverse and
integration most certainly should not be
confused with assimilation
it comes from a neutral position one can
say so one can say that policies geared
towards Refugee integration have been
seriously neglected by all governments
over the past 30 years or so
my Lord's in my view the lens of
migration management is inappropriate
for Asylum and leads to unnecessary
polarization and toxicity
the UK Refugee and Asylum system should
not be lumped together with General
immigration policy
the former is wholly morally grounded
the latter is more opaque
and so immigration through refugees and
Asylum is founded on a wholly different
set of principles
at our first Hearing in Birmingham our
commission heard from refugees
themselves local officials and voluntary
organizations all raised major concerns
about the way the UK's current Refugee
and Asylum system functions the
polarizing media discourse in this area
was particularly identified as the enemy
of fairness
recent successful and country-specific
settlement schemes should be
distinguished from the main subject I'm
talking about they have come with
funding and resourcing to facilitate the
integration of a spec of specified
groups of new arrivals
but the same cannot be said for those
who apply for asylum in the UK
poor resourcing and the unprecedented
unprecedented waiting times for those in
the system and ensuing trauma and
uncertainty make long-term integration
much more difficult for anyone who
exercises their right and it is a right
my lords according to the Geneva
Convention to apply for asylum in the
United Kingdom
additional damage I'm afraid is caused
by legislation which puts into statute a
two-tiered Asylum system depending on
the method of Entry
we can all understand the argument for
deterrence and I think we should send
back quickly those who clearly are not
genuine refugees
but the current system has the effect of
punishing those who legitimately claim
asylum in the UK through putting severe
restrictions on access to English
language training work which has already
been mentioned and good accommodation
and the current policy doesn't seem to
me to deter a single person it's a
fiction that government policy has
increased deterrence
finally my lords I'd like to raise a
point about unaccompanied Asylum Seeker
children I believe that they should be
treated as children first and foremost
the British state has a duty of care to
those children
sadly in many circumstances this is not
being provided unaccompanied Asylum
Seeker children are often processed as
adults on arrival at the UK border
they're being sent to adult
accommodation and it's left to local
authorities to try and pick up the
pieces later on
these children are usually not provided
with access to the health and most
especially the mental health support
that they require and sadly some simply
disappear into child trafficking sex
work and human slavery
there are serious issues about the age
assessment assessment of people who
claim to be children and the disputes
process on that matter but these must
now be resolved in a way that is fast
and fair and imaginative and if it does
that it will also be accurate
my lords the UK must play its role in
working to alleviate these defects
through an improved system that respects
the rights of refugees and Asylum
Seekers whilst also winning the aqueous
acquiescence of the British public
and my lords despite my probably
sensible And Timely demotion on the
speaker list I am nevertheless delighted
to speak in this very moving debate and
thank my brother the Archbishop of
Canterbury for bringing this to us I I
thank you all said hello bro both and
for his very kind words on our preaching
earlier this year and I can assure him
not not on this occasion but on almost
every other occasion when I Rise to
speak it is to speak about the Christian
Gospel which whose values underpin
everything I am about to say I was also
very very moved by Lord Singh
um who who quoted the the Jewish and
Christian scriptures to us and that is
such a powerful sign of the generous uh
spirit of the Sikh Faith which we can
all learn so much from and and thank you
indeed for the the three very powerful
Maiden speeches we've heard today
um I I want to emphasize a a really a
small but significant point
and that is that getting this right
and doing the right thing is a blessing
for all of us
everyone in our society and the best way
of Shifting public opinion whose anxiety
about this I believe is fueled by the
dysfunction of our current system
you know the hard truth is our Asylum
system simply doesn't treat everyone the
same it doesn't give people the dignity
safety and agency that their Humanity
deserves Lord Lily everyone is our
neighbor of course
um we can't we can't take everybody but
we must therefore even more so have a
fair system for everyone
but dehumanizing language just promotes
fear a threat of destitution is being
used as a deterrent and children
children are treated as if they are
adults yet in our own country amongst
our own people in our churches other
Faith groups and communities some things
have gone really well such as the homes
for Ukraine scheme where many people
have found a home other family members
have joined them people have been able
to get work this is really good
but why my lords has our response to
people fleeing other conflicts being
different
currently the family definition in our
Asylum system would not even allow
someone to join their sibling even if
they were the last remaining relative
and being able to work and contribute is
a long long way off the tragedy of our
system lies in its exceptionalism that
means people get differential treatment
usually because of the their country of
origin and this underpins the
nationality and borders act and I fear
further legislative action will be the
same but we could learn from what's
happening in our communities and again
Lord Lily let me assure you you asked us
directly about integration
I mean I don't know where to begin
um you know in in so many I'm and I do
mean hundreds and hundreds of parishes
and schools and indeed in other Faith
communities up and down our country that
is what we're doing
um in English language classes in
befriending people in teaching people
um yeah there's lots about the Church of
England which could be better I'll be
the first to admit it but actually this
is something we are doing alongside
others and it shows the best of British
so
we need a system that will simply
provide safe and legal routes for
everyone to have equal opportunities to
apply for Asylum and all I'm saying is I
think this would be good for us
as well as for the people who are
fleeing unimaginable conflict and Evil
finally when it comes to being able to
work
the Church of England alongside the
refugee Council and the government's own
migration advisory committee is a
long-standing support supporter of the
lift the ban campaign
my lords I I say this to you and like
many of us would wish to say more but I
think the Archbishop of Canterbury did
actually say most of it
I say this as winter arrives
um and it's cold
and a cost of living crisis will
inevitably affect British people's
capacity to be hospitable
and I want to say simply this a
functioning Asylum system is not a
threat to our social cohesion as some
fear or predict
but a dysfunctional unfair one is
as every small child knows this time of
the year as Lord cormack has mentioned
Mary and Joseph came looking for
somewhere to stay
but there was no room at the Inn
saying no
accusing those who are hospitable of
being naive
passing the buck
that's the easy thing to do but saying
yes with a fair and equal system for
everyone now this also opens up
blessings for everyone
right
may I thank the most Reverend pellet for
the enormous opportunity he's given us
by challenging us to respond to the
enormous problem of force migration
I speak today about religious
persecution as a driver probably the key
driver for forced migration and if I may
uh in uh tell my my Noble friends that
we have with us today His Highness
Prince hazim of the azidis all will
recall that the yazidis are perhaps the
most persecutive minority of all at the
moment and of course there are many
others as well but these are victims of
genocide and genocide is of course the
worst crime in the UN convention
assembly
so
I and my colleagues have worked hard in
recent years to do everything we can to
support the azitis in their in feebled
situation in camps in Northern Iraq and
we've worked hard and we have come out
with one or two important conclusions
that I put before you and hope that
women have the opportunity to discuss
privately or in groups at another of
another place
we have formed that the Winds of
dialogue under the chairmanship of
Bishop Alistair Redfern with the support
of Canon Edmond Newell the supporter of
Cannon Paul Edmondson and other members
of Westminster Abbey the dean himself
and with the spiritual Council of of the
yazidis which is headed by the prince
himself we have tied ourselves into
another oppressed minority another
religious persecuted minority who have
broken through and become immensely
successful to give us an example of what
can be done and that is the LDS
Latter-Day Saints otherwise known as the
Mormons where we have as our co-chairman
Edward
Jeffrey Holland and work hard with uh
Sharon Eubank and with the U.S Friends
of the Mr Foundation which is the
generating energy of what is going on
we brought ourselves together because we
learned that the the excuse for the
genocidal actions by ISIS against the
azitis was that they were supposed to
worship the devil and this has led us
looking in great detail over a number of
years into this problem issue of
refugees everywhere forced migration we
have come to the conclusion that
religious persecution is a very very
important driver of force migration and
it without looking at the religious
persecution angle I do not think that
you can recover we do not think that you
can recover the lives the livelihoods of
the agencies of those who have been
beaten and oppressed and sex-slaved and
other disgusting activities that humans
undertake when they lose their thread of
morality
so we have worked intensively in the
campus we have been practical in terms
of building Health Centers equipping
them and running them and we have also
brought in music I.T English language
and business training and now we are
starting to be able to offer jobs
we're particularly focused on music
because the yazidis themselves their
prayers are all sung and we found that
the onslaught on themselves on them was
matched or intensified by the onslaught
on their own religion and that meant
that those who held the music in their
heads the priests of the azitis
spiritual Council they were the ones at
the end who the Isis were targeting
indeed at one point I found I could only
count somewhere over 10 remaining
priests and this meant that their entire
as it was Sistine Chapel Westminster
Abbey accountability cathedral was in
the heads of just a very very few
priests and those were being targeted by
their bitter enemy the Isis Rebels so we
recorded the music with the prince of
the Adidas agreement and it's stored in
bodilian library that can never be lost
again but it's given us an understanding
of what happens when your religion is in
fact not attacked because it does seem
that your religion is a key part of your
identity of your personality of course
in Britain we like to think that
religion doesn't count we simply discard
the idea the knowledge that 83 of the
globe belongs to a faith One Faith or
another the principle one being
Christianity the second but I mean Islam
then we have Hinduism and so on and then
we have wonderful minority faiths such
as the yazidi faith so understanding the
reason for the onstood was one of our
key first efforts and we have managed to
articulate write down what the aziti
faith is and the princess predecessor
the former Prince that's hardly dead he
said this was the first ever time that
Faith had been properly written down
accurately without being targeted by an
onslaught that it was wrong because of
course the whole uh supposed enemy that
the the azitis are supposed to be rests
on this bizarre concept that they
worship the devil of course that is not
the case at all but it's very odd how
humans when an idea Gets In Their Heads
how they refuse to dislodge it and
there's still an awful lot of thinking
with that at the moment so firstly we
understood the reason of the onslaught
and then we worked out how to tackle it
and now today I'm very very happy to say
that instead of a a a a a disaster we
believe we have a way out we believe we
have a way forward and in that belief
which we're writing down and researching
and we'll be presenting we have the
support of unhcr we have the support of
the World Health Organization and we
hope very much indeed that the formula
we are developing may be of use and
value elsewhere too and the yazidis
themselves are very happy if that
suffering can help others much of it is
based on music and I'm very pleased to
say we've been able to perform to King
Charles uh to the bodilian library to
Western Abby doesn't George's winds are
Axel tarti Singh unto God is basically
where we are coming from and I would
suggest that it is time to restart our
look at refugees and see them as a
tremendously capable group of people and
to help them flourish to help them
perform and to help them be successful
and no longer to be victims
my lord it's a privilege to follow the
uh nobody Nicholson and we have heard
three excellent meeting speeches I think
my Noble Friends lady twycross Russo and
the right Reverend the visible Leicester
for their excellent contributions to
this debate well as I think the most uh
reverent primate for the opportunity to
relate this important question today
it's timely for many reasons in addition
to the seasonal context they're offered
to us by the noble Lord Lord Cormac and
the remainder by my Noble friend lady
chakrabarti that tomorrow is human
rights day only two weeks ago the Home
Secretary admitted that we had lost
control of our borders and in that loss
of control we have a gridlock Asylum
system
144 000 people are waiting an initial
decision on the Asylum applications 74
for six months or more that is six
months of being unable to work to access
key services or accommodation and most
importantly for a significant proportion
of these people unable to live without
the fear and the torment of being sent
back at the risk of prosecution and
torture
over a third of from five countries with
Grant rates of 80 percent meaning that
they will likely have a legitimate claim
to Asylum
and there's a the number Lord kavlail
emphasized within this appalling chaos
there are Children at Risk
in the year to September of those who
applied over 14 000 were children
including 5 152 who are unaccompanied
and many of these children far too many
have gone missing have disappeared
including 39
children child refugees who have gone
missing in Kent
my Lord the welfare of those children
the home office has a legal duty to
safeguard and it is failing so to do
but not only have children gone missing
this last year
there was a 212 percent rise in age
disputes
it's worth emphasizing the home office
policy and this was revised so that
those who look significantly over 18 are
treated as adults a policy that has
resulted in children as young as 14
being placed in Immigration detention or
alone in adult accommodation facing
significant risk of harm a breach of our
duty of care and of the provisions of
the UN Convention of the rights of the
child and our own consequent legislation
thanks my Lord I ask the noble Lord the
minister a question that he must have
anticipated
I caught Tim louton from the record of
the home Affairs Select Committee
hearing on the 23rd of November when he
role played as follows
I'm a 16 year old orphan from an East
African country escaping a war zone and
religious persecution and I have a
sibling who is legally in the United
Kingdom
what is a safe and legal route for me to
come to the United Kingdom
if he's unable to better the home
secretaries floundering and seeming
inability to provide a coherent answer
and her permanent secretary's offer that
they should engage with the unhcr while
at the same time admitting that there
are many countries in Africa and indeed
elsewhere but it's not possible to apply
for Asylum via the unhcr should we
unfair that the principles informing
contemporary UK Asylum and Refugee
policy I'm not in compliance with the
refugee convention and that that is by
Design
my final point is about the government's
known as notorious Rwanda policy an
immoral policy that shames Britain
on the release of government documents
about the process by which Rwanda was
selected for offshoring of Asylum
Seekers we saw the degree through which
the then prime minister and the Home
Secretary overrode the concerns of
senior officials their own equality
impact assessment the unhcr the British
High Commissioner for turwanda and the
UK's International Ambassador for human
rights
so now we spent 140 million pounds of
what will be receiving in return well
the prospect of years of ongoing
litigation despite among many of our key
allies and partners
the disapproval of the unhcr another
Supreme National agencies and the
further erosion of our reputation for
compassion and adherence to
International world
in its latest country report the U.S
state Department said that among the
things that characterize Rwanda are
arbitrary detention ill treatment
torture and official and unofficial
detention and the fact that fair trial
standards are routinely floted
last Sunday the U.S Secretary of State
called president kagame he reported
having discussed credible reports
indicating that Rwanda continues to
support the M23 Rebel group and has its
armed forces inside the DRC and an oral
question yesterday in your lordship's
house the normal Lord Goldsmith twice
reminded us that this egregious behavior
and sponsoring conflict in an evening
country undermines peace efforts and is
causing insecurity and significant human
suffering there so much so that the FCD
will have raised their concerns at the
highest levels in Rwanda
can I ask the minister how our
assessments of the robustness of
Judicial Systems of the likelihood of
arbitrary arrests and the propensity for
agents of the state to use torture in
Rwanda differ from that of U.S state
Department
I'm interested to know if we have a
superior methodological practice that
might explain this disparity in Outlook
of course the government is right to
emphasize the importance
of breaking the grip of people Smugglers
but there is no evidence at all that the
Rwanda policy will accomplish that since
it was announced the numbers of arrivals
have gone up not down
so thanks may be forgiven for thinking
that the government is happy to invest
money in a policy that is purely
symbolic small boat arrivals continue at
record levels during past at least to a
lack of safe and legal routes for Asylum
well as we Face significant
systemic challenges to our immigration
and Asylum system and it's time we
confronted them constructively and not
just symbolically I work on this debate
there's a step towards doing exactly
that I commend the most Reverend
privilege proposals at a good starting
point
particularly when they read in the
context of my right honorable friend
Yvette Cooper's detailed interviews
today
yeah
my lords I too would like to thank the
most Reverend trumpet the Archbishop of
Canterbury for introducing this
important debate and doing so so
effectively
it is essential that we discuss this
issue in the way it has been framed
because the debate about Asylum and
Refugee policy has become very toxic we
have lost sight of the principles we
should guide this policy
challenges facing Asylum and Refugee
policy are quite different from those
facing voluntary migration policy
every country of course has the right to
control voluntary migration and develop
policies to meet their needs
but we've got to remember that
involuntary migration is different
Asylum Seekers and refugees do not move
out of choice they are forced to flee
the persecution and other intolerable
conditions
unfortunately debates about Asylum and
voluntary migration have been conflated
sometimes I fear deliberately
this has confused the issue and has led
to a very negative and ill-informed
public debate of course public opinion
matters but those in Authority have the
responsibility to explain
inappropriate terminology has crept into
into this discourse and has influenced
policy for example the term illegal
refugees is used by many even by those
in authority and as we know under
international law this is a misnomer
the 1951 Refugee convention is the
Cornerstone of international Refugee
protection regime and we are parted to
this convention and we have a duty to
comply with its provisions
but the unhcr said that our current
Asylum Refugee policy undermines
established International Protection Law
and practices they said that
Arrangements that seek to transfer
refugees and Asylum Seekers of third
countries in the absence of sufficient
safeguards and standards simply shift
Asylum responsibilities evade
International obligations and are
contrary to the latter and the spirit of
the refugee Council my lords a country
which Prides itself of promoting rule of
law here and abroad and wants to
influence International standards this
is a damning statement
the nationality and borders act will
create differential status for Asylum
Seekers based on their mode of travel to
the UK it will divide people into
genuine Refugee and failed Asylum
sequels through creating for the
creation of two two-tier system
furthermore under the ACT Asylum sequels
now face the threat of criminal charges
and a four-year prison sentence for
entering so-called illegally this policy
is not only contrary to the spirit the
spirit and the latter of the refugee
convention it is estimated that this
misguided prevent measures will cost
2.7 billion pounds
and in trying to justify the provisions
of this act some have said that the 1959
convention
it it in the 1951 convention is a cold
war Relic with outdated definitions and
not suitable for the types of challenges
you face today
in my view my lords the principles
contained in the convention provide a
Humane and compassionate framework which
should remain the Cornerstone of our
Asylum policy as it was so eloquently
stated by Lord Griffiths of Perry Port
who talked earlier
it is deeply regrettable that our
policies now based on two guiding
principles that of deterrence and
creating an hofstad environment
consequences of which have been dire
what we need is a refugee protection
system which provides safe and legal
routes and trees refugees with
compassion and Humanity
this will be a better deterrence against
Smugglers than costly and effective
surveillance at sea while there are
specific schemes for people from
countries such as Ukraine Hong Kong and
Afghanistan for many others no such
routes exist at present Asylum Seekers
must be present in the UK before
applying for for Asylum if no safe route
is available irregular entry is the only
option which of course the Smugglers
exploit unfortunately in the recent
years the government have severely
reduced the amount of people coming
through Global Recycling schemes and
have relied on inconsistent and peaceful
approach and creating an hostile
environment and instead of expanding
Refugee settlement programs and dealing
with Asylum backlog that has left over a
hundred thousand people waiting for over
six months billions of pounds have been
wasted on deterrence measures that do
not work
meanwhile as we've heard thousands of
people are left in limbo banned from
working and living in Dreadful isolated
accommodation
a more Humane approach would be to open
up targeted and limited legal Asylum
routes with a new humanitarian Visa
granting Asylum Seekers
my lords the challenges of forced
migration are unlikely to Abate they're
likely to be exacerbated by climate
change it is estimated that by 250 200
million people globally each year will
require humanitarian assistance due to
climate change this underlines the
importance of international cooperation
to develop responses which are
compassionate Humane and preserve human
dignity working with the United Nations
and other multilateral institutions to
find ways of dealing with this should be
a priority having left the EU Britain is
no longer a part of Dublin III apart
from France no equivalent Arrangement
has been made either bilaterally or
between the EU and the UK to date in
2023 the global Refugee Forum will be
held in Geneva these are opportunities
to strengthen International cooperation
to develop viable in viable
International responses to tackle the
plight of of of refugee Seekers my lords
the current situation is untenable and a
blot on our image as a country which has
a proud history of helping a welcoming
refugees and I do look forward to the
noble law The Minister's response
was it's a pleasure to follow the naval
baroness parents prashar we are not
often afforded the opportunity to look
at Asylum policy forensically and
dispassionately so I thank my Noble
friend the Archbishop of Canterbury for
choosing this debate
I congratulate those who have given
their Maiden speeches today
I note my registered interests as a
trustee of reset and a principle of ramp
I begin with laying out clear principles
that come from how ancient Israel was
called to treat refugees these are
welcome treat with dignity as fellow
humans support enable self-support and
integration
it's no secret that we are not doing the
mechanics of Welcome through Asylum
processing well
the application's backlog means we are
both unable to prioritize those in need
or humanely return those not recognized
as refugees
they were close to 140 000 unanswered
applications in the system by the end of
September so men women and children in
limbo unable to rebuild their lives this
is not treating people with dignity
chronic under investment in both people
and systems at the home office has
caused this
but there are workable Solutions recruit
more caseworkers set up a dedicated case
clearance unit that effectively triages
currently 35 of the backlog is
applications from five countries with
Grant rates of over 85 percent including
countries with an acceptance level of 98
percent
Asylum law identifies safe countries so
there should be no barrier in
prioritizing those we know have credible
Asylum claims and urgently need our
support
this would involve a cost but if we were
to allow Asylum Seekers to work after
six months of waiting for a decision
enabling them to support themselves then
money would be recouped by the extractor
and what is the real cost especially on
children dealing with past trauma while
not knowing their future is safe
current policy does not allow claim for
Asylum outside the UK except for
ukrainians Afghans and Hong Kong
last week the minister confirmed outside
of the limited schemes available the
government does not propose to offer any
more
therefore I ask are we not pushing
vulnerable people into perilous Journeys
if there is no safe way to travel
under existing safe route schemes there
have been examples of success
the Ukraine scheme has seen us welcome
very many
could I could the minister comment on
suggestions that this safe route will be
closed to new applicants in the near
future
equally both ARA and acrs have seen
significant numbers of Afghani arrivals
could the minister comment on the
difficulties that remain for some hiding
for their safety inside Afghanistan or
apparently blocked in neighboring
countries
the government needs to commit to
expanding re-settlement routes working
with unhcr and instigating humanitarian
visas that people could apply for at
embassies
further family reunion cannot continue
to be neglected
family reunion numbers have dropped by
36 percent from pre-pandemic levels
ninety percent of those who use this
route are women and children
we must seek to maintain and restore
family Unity wherever possible
so could the minister in his response
affirmed the government's commitment to
family reunion as a safe route and
dropped the argument that this acts as a
pull factor when the evidence is clear
that it is not
some this week have called for a
complete reversal in Immigration policy
but I would urge the government to
realign the system with the outward
facing values we hold as a nation with
our Rich history of giving Sanctuary to
those in need
of course we should ascertain whether
individuals are in fact true refugees
but this needs to be done in accord with
International agreements and the
upholding of Human Rights
it is simply wrong to abdicate our moral
and legal responsibility to consider a
person's claim to Asylum on their
arrival in this country here is where
they must be dealt with
I noted earlier there is much to be
proud of from the roots for Afghans
ukrainians and Hong Kong
through these schemes we have
established good practice
there is therefore now an opportunity to
expand Community sponsorship and develop
a single Refugee sponsorship scheme one
which is scalable flexible and
accessible to all refugees so we don't
reinvent it every time a new crisis
arrives
I encourage the government to see this
as an important element of its
commitment to safe and legal routes one
which may move us towards an environment
of hospitality rather than hostility
will the minister agree to meet with me
and those working to design a proposed
single Refugee sponsorship scheme to
explore this together
two quick comments before I close Lord
robot and I will write to you as the
lead Bishop for Education about Worship
in schools
lordly Lord Lily ask one of us
or others of these Ventures to show you
examples of what is happening locally
we can all give you plenty of examples
when one sees the faces of those in need
and listens to their voices as the
Archbishop called us to do we learn that
what ultimately pushes someone to escape
tyranny while carrying immense grief is
Hope
we need an asylum system that provides
sanctuary and gives the opportunity for
people to rebuild hope Jeremiah wrote I
know the plans I have for you plans to
prosper you and not harm you plans to
give you hope and a future
it will be political maturity and
courageous compassionate leadership not
hostility and defensiveness in policy
that can bring people hope
yeah my lords I'm always amazed by the
simple fact that when I was born 83
years ago at the beginning of the second
World War
there were two billion people in the
world and there are now 8 billion people
factored to increase four-fold
and that's an explanation if you need
any other of climate change
and if you add climate change to bad
government Wars and extremism it success
is surprising that forced migration is
on the scale that it is and frankly
likely to get worse
I have a family member who worked for
Mary's Stokes International now known as
MSI reproductive choices
she's working on bringing Family
Planning help to women in developing
countries including West Africa I always
say to her that no one in the world is
doing more practical help to than you
are
obviously the UK will want to make its
contribution to helping with this
problem
we always do help with these
International problems and has have an
outstanding record
but we are a small country
we already we are heavily populated
heavily populated country
and since the Blair government opened
the front Gates net migration has been
at a very high level
we have been importing a city of the
size of Newcastle upon Tyne every year
pretty well since the beginning of the
century
in the last 12 months he was two
Newcastle upon times because the net
migration figure was over half a million
this has had massive consequences for
housing and public services
particularly as my Noble friend Baron
stole I thought in the very perceptive
speech pointed out in the poorer part of
our country where immigrants mainly go
the labor and Trade union activist Paul
Embry described in his book despised the
the catastrophic effect on his hometown
of dagenham
that had been in severe environmental
consequences environmental consequences
the Times columnist Emma Duncan pointed
this out recently in an article where
the headline was Green Space must Trump
migration
then there is the threat to social
cohesion which is a a product of
Lancashire I know very well
all the while public opinion which is
strongly against Mass immigration has
been ignored and if you ignore people's
views in the Democracy you eventually
get a raspberry we got the raspberry it
was brexit and brexit was partly caused
by the weaponizing of immigration
so how do we Square this circle yeah how
do we make a contribution to the
international problem
and yet cope with the serious downsize
my answer is the same as Lord lilies
let's prioritize
I will give maximum priority to those in
greatest need and those in greatest
needs are the genuine Asylum Seekers
the real refugees
properly defined
if you give priority to genuine refugees
it means less room for other migrants
I'm particularly appalled by the
recruitment teams that go out from the
UK to hire doctors nurses and care
workers for the National Health Service
the countries we hire them from need
them far more than we do I remember
paying a visit as a part of a
parliamentary delegation to Botswana
whether when the AIDS problem was at its
height I asked how they were dealing
with the drugs
putting out the drugs necessary
they said we didn't have enough nurses
why didn't have a nurse enough nurses
because they're all gone to the NHS
because they got more money there that
is the consequence are in my view
immoral
migration policy in that area I'm an
economist in my view much the same
arguments apply to economic migrants I
remember a Jacob a Jamaican politician
saying to me how do you expect us to
build a modern society where an every
year half our graduates disappear to the
United States or to Europe
the CBI says it wants more migraines
make immigrants to fill vacancies this
is ridiculous I started out and ran a
successful medium-sized business
Manpower planning is a major part of the
job you have to think and think ahead
and train the CBI should stop moaning
and see this as an opportunity and
social of the government
so I would readily reduce the number of
migrate migrants of this kind which are
far larger in number
if you had anything you could then have
an increase in the number of Asylum
Seekers coming to this country and could
widen the scope for that for those
people
finally there is the question of illegal
immigration across the town the problem
here is that those who criticize it
never put forward any solution saying
that we should have more legal Roots is
not a solution because it leaves the
traffickers in business and while they
are in business people will take their
chances I looked I listened carefully to
the remarks of the noble uh
propellant the Archbishop and also the
bishop of Durham on this point and
neither of them filled in this hole in
their argument I'm sorry to say
we have a new team in place including my
Noble friend who sits on the front
Bachelor welcome to his place their
their watchwords in my view should be
compassion and control if they keep
those two words in mind they won't go
far wrong
okay
my lords as we've heard this morning
from Ugandan Asians fleeing Idi Amin to
French huguenots fleeing persecution
Britain has a proud Heritage of
welcoming those in need to these Shores
but tragically Refugee and Asylum policy
have now become one of our most divided
and polarized debates
we urgently need a better and unifying
story a clear narrative about Refugee
and Asylum policy as distinct from
illegal migration and a better and
effective National Refugee strategy
I'm delighted that it is the most
reverent primate who has called this
debate today it is the judeo-christian
foundation of this nation that makes it
the country that people fleeing War
intolerance and conflict want to come to
principles of fairness safety and
dignity
of course there is no question that
control and integration are also
Paramount
the government has a duty to its own
people and our failure over decades to
properly control our borders has fueled
the anxiety which underpins much Asylum
and Refugee discourse
but it is not those in need who are
driving this
according to the ons Small Boat
Crossings accounted for only 3.5 percent
of the total immigration figures in 2022
to give a broader example of what is
happening 277
000 non-eu citizens arrived on long-term
study visas 151
000 people arrived for work 89 000
Ukrainian Visa scheme holders arrived
and over a hundred thousand bno Hong
Kong has arrived meanwhile an estimated
35
000 people arrived by small boats the
majority of whom applied for Asylum
if we want to reduce net migration
numbers Asylum claims are the smallest
of categories
but today's theme though is how we
balance compassion with control as my
Noble friend Lord Forum has just um
mentioned
so my argument is that there will be no
constructive way forward until the
government addresses three public
priorities the first control of borders
the second control of our Asylum system
and the third controlled safe and legal
roots
I begin with the control of our borders
this matters because narratives about
the Calais border are often equated with
headline migration numbers and wrongly
tied into Refugee policy
it also matters because by putting the
numbers in context it becomes clear that
the catastrophizing rhetoric about the
so-called crisis is overblown
we do need Clarity in our language
one of the reasons why 56 percent of
those polled say immigration is too high
is because politicians in the media
relentlessly use terms such as illegal
migration and do not distinguish between
illegal migration economic migration and
those who have been trafficked or are
seeking Refuge or Asylum
this my lords is disingenuous
when I explain the numbers I have just
shared with the house people are
genuinely stunned and they say they had
no idea that the number of people
claiming Asylum here was so small in
comparison with those That We're
actually inviting to come here
but if we want to regain our borders
control of our borders diplomacy with
our European allies should be our first
Port of Call I am pleased that the Prime
Minister has been seeking to deepen his
collaboration with his French
counterpart on this matter it is the
most likely way of genuine control being
restored
while control of our borders needs
diplomacy retaining control of our
Asylum system is a matter of
administrative competence
if application and decision rates stay
the same as the last year by June 2024
the backlog will be over 200
000 cases
the status quo is quite simply not
sustainable we must take immediate
action to clear the backlog
I was pleased to see in the times that
the government is looking to fast-track
claims from countries with a high Grant
rate as well as fast tracking those from
safe countries where claims that are
very unlikely to be credible
if this policy were enacted at a stroke
a considerable amount of the burden on
the taxpayer would be lifted
we must also improve the processing of
cases while Britain made only 16 400
Asylum decisions in the year to
September 2022 France made nearly double
that number of decisions between July
and September alone we can quite
obviously do better with our decision
making
much of this though will take time but
given we are in a time of Labor
shortages it is a matter of pure common
sense that people who are in the backlog
should be granted the right to work in
fact I profoundly agree with the most
reverent primate not just granted the
right to work but expected to work the
arguments for this are fundamentally
conservative and I made them at some
length during the passage of a
nationality and borders bill so won't go
into them in depth here but in short we
need their skills and we don't need to
be paying for their accommodation or
supporting their incomes they can do
this themselves surely this at the very
least should be addressed
as I come to conclude I want to turn to
the final area where we need to develop
control in our Asylum system controlled
safe and legal routes for genuine Asylum
Seekers it signs extraordinary that
whether you are a victim of the yazidi
genocide of State oppression in Eritrea
there is no safe route to come here
I would suggest that if the minister
laid out controlled roots for people
from Iran to Eritrea who genuinely need
our support he would find broad support
in the house for getting a grip on the
border and would significantly
depolarize this divisive issue
my lords we need a British national
Refugee policy which is grounded in The
Best of British values ranging from
compassion to control this is the only
viable Way Forward
my lords it really is a privilege and a
pleasure to follow baronette Stroud with
whom I agree entirely
my laws have been a lot of references to
religion and Christianity this morning I
suppose not surprisingly given that it's
the debate in the name of the Archbishop
of Canterbury but I want to point out
for the avoidance of doubt I am not a
Christian I am an atheist and I come to
these matters from the concept of what
is happening to others could so easily
be happening to me and if I wouldn't
want it to happen to me how dare I allow
it to happen to others I also wish to
commend the work that I see being done
by all faiths and none and I celebrate
that work I also wish to congratulate
the three Maiden speeches the right
Reverend prelent the bishop of Leicester
my dear friend from the West Midlands
and my Noble friend Lord sahota and of
course RNs twicross
my lords at times of Crisis and when
countries and their systems are under
increasing pressure we have even more
need to adhere to International
standards and agreed human rights
obligations as so eloquently outlined by
my Noble friends baroness chakrabarti
and Lord Griffis of very port
indeed my lords in times of Crisis we
need certainty and need to abide by
principles and standards that I believe
Define us as a Civilized Nation
how we treat those most in need defines
us long after our actions therefore my
lords the demonization stereotyping
misrepresentation and the defamation of
Asylum Seekers and migrants by the media
politicians and government ministers is
I believe deeply reprehensible serves no
one and does nothing other than fuel
hatred Despair and greater isolation
only when we deal with the reasons why
people flee their countries will we ever
reduce the need for refuge and until we
can achieve resolution of these issues
we must meet our International
obligations indeed I would say our moral
obligations
my Lord's the UK Asylum system as we
have heard is in an utter state of
collapse it is overwhelmed by back clock
backlogs which government policy has
created
the impact is one of Crisis thousands of
people stuck for long and indefinite
periods frequently in conditions that
are inadequate unsanitary overcrowded
and even unlawful causing disease
distress and there is every indication
to conclude deaths
there are significantly more people now
dying in this system including babies
the last three home secretaries
discounting Grant chaps whose term of
office lasted less than a week have made
crossing the channel by small boat a
focal point
during their respective terms they have
each contributed to the sense that these
Crossings constitute my lords a national
threat
pretty Patel significantly cracked
cranked up rhetoric and policy that is
hostile to people seeking Asylum the
current home secretary has continued
this
describing people seeking Asylum as
Invaders and did so barely 24 hours
after a fire bomb attack upon people
seeking Asylum detained in Dover
shameful in the extreme
the express aim of such policy my lords
is deterrence and primarily expressed as
deterrence of Small Boat Crossings but
the real policy aim is the deterrence of
seeking Asylum
so we witness a dangerous cocktail of
deterrence and the demonization of
Asylum Seekers no God no good has come
from this policy and no good can come
from it we need safe clear obvious ways
to seek Asylum no more confusion no more
ducking and Diving no more home
secretaries using Asylum Seekers and
desperate migrants as political Capital
to shore up their bid for power in the
future no more dangerous rhetoric aided
and abetted by a right-wing printed
media that fills me with shame
we urgently need the creation of real
and accessible safe routes by which
people especially people with family and
connections here can seek asylum in the
United Kingdom
and we need the government to respect
international human rights and Asylum
law in the case of every person who
exercises their right to seek asylum in
this country
my lords I wish to quote from a briefing
from the refugee and migrant children's
Consortium
over recent years we have seen the
government significantly erode the
rights of children seeking Asylum not
just by making the Asylum system less
accessible and more punitive but by also
excluding them from the child protection
and Welfare Frameworks that should apply
to all children in this country
regardless of nationality ethnicity or
immigration status
my lords
if such an appalling indictment does not
shame this government and fill us all
with a sense of Shame then I wonder what
kind of country we have become
but let me finish
on a positive note
a man who experienced the breast The
Best of British decency when he arrived
here under the Kinder transport
my Noble friend Lord dubs reminded us
that we must give hope
my Lord um sorry I said two atheists in
a row a bit like 73 buses I I greatly
like my Noble friends or Cashman would
call him a friend but I don't actually
like following him in debate the fact is
he was trained to hold an audience and I
haven't been
uh but I do start with this story on my
maiden visit to albanus I'm 20 years ago
driving into
Toronto from the airport I was struck by
the number of uh high grade fast cars
overtaking us all the time and there
were Maser offices uh BMWs Mercedes
Bentleys Porsches
and I pointed this out to my I asked my
driver about and he said well there's
one only you better notice about them
just look at their number plates and
they all of them were still bearing the
number plates and other registration
marks that they had born on the streets
of the European Capital Cities from
which they had been stolen nobody had
thought it necessary to change them the
so powerful and established were the
criminal gangs there that there was no
need to hide that criminality
uh under the fact is uh that that
Albania as their Ambassador told the
commons a select committee I think two
days ago is an obviously safe country
um
it isn't Riven by Civil War it isn't
suffering acutely from climate change
and all the perils far uh flood drought
famine that go with that it's just a
lawless country and the point is that if
ever one could say that the great Rush
of people coming the young fit albanians
coming here are economic migrants and
should be if we're to have any
credibility at all in terms of
controlling our borders should be
instant clear removed it's them of
course you treat them with respect with
compassion events discriminate but you
look realistically at the problem and
the one reason I tell that story above
all is this
they are crossing the channel putting
their lives risk because they're hoping
to improve their lives how much are more
uh May one expect those who genuinely
have some
poor persecution to flee from how much
more likely are there to do so and what
that makes the point that I know friend
Lord Carlisle made the policies this
government adopts to deter people from
crossing the channel don't work can't
work won't work
uh and uh uh of course the law
Archbishop was writing saying that the
people trafficking has got to be
confronted uh on an international basis
and everything possible one would have
hoped for but intelligence LED uh
attacks on the uh ease with which still
apparently boat sail from France and
Belgium but
um meantime recognizing policies don't
work that is surely a compelling reason
there's so many if argue to relax this
absurd 12-month ban on employment they
should work uh it's there's no point it
doesn't deter them to have the ban and
that's the only reason that anybody has
ever suggested why you had it in the
first place
Outsourcing of uh of our
responsibilities well now I take I have
to say a more nuanced a less sensorious
view than most of your Lordships and
certainly the uh the spiritual benches
in the house it's a I think a difficult
Point even if the Rwandan threat of
those arriving from the channel
Crossings doesn't deter it doesn't
follow that we shouldn't be making uh
Arrangements such as is proposed here
and I don't know where I've read and I
would hope and imagine that certainly
the Bishops benches have read the three
Oxford professorial papers that have
been written about all this circularized
under the edges of uh policy exchange
and it's a much more difficult problem
than uh it's so tempting and easy just
to stand on one's moral high horse and
say it's obviously wrong the
responsibility is ours and we can't
shift it assuming it's legal and of
course we still await the outcome of
that but if it's legal well then excuse
me it's a much deeper more difficult
argument than this hitherto uh being a
recognized on the other point made in
these professorial papers is it's all
very well saying we must have safe
routes we're not alone in not having
safe routes they don't have safe routes
for the general run of
aspiring Asylum Seekers or economic
migrants in Canada and America or indeed
most other countries because they would
be swamped we need them the archbishops
plainly writing there's a new a refugee
convention to meet the acute problems
which are as everybody recognize is
going to get ever more acute with
climate change migration is good been
held and when we think we've got a
problem now but you ain't seen nothing
yet
my lords I'd like to thank the most
Reverend product for encouraging us to
consider the question of Asylum from a
moral position but I must warn those
who've made such interesting Maiden
speeches and I warmly welcome them that
debate in this house aren't always so
erudite or ethical
one concern regularly when we discuss
this topic we're urged to deploy our
moral sentiments in terms of feeling
compassion for refugees
what might it be emotionally
manipulative to suggest that policy
should be decided by such one-sided
emotional concerns
there are millions and millions of
people who could have their lives
enhanced if they lived in the UK
and when I watched the news and see the
plights of those around the world
suffering I'm tearful I want to do
something desperately but as the
Archbishop himself admits we cannot take
all the world's suffering as refugees
here we have to prioritize that doesn't
make us immoral I therefore feel
uncomfortable when some accuse those who
raise concerns about the numbers
arriving in small boats as lacking a
disposition of generosity or not caring
isn't that demonizing and dehumanizing
language too
let's not pretend that this is an easy
moral question for all the moral
righteousness expressed here today
can I ask what is the moral difference
between a man fleeing a war-torned
country considered legal versus a man
fleeing grinding poverty which isn't and
I think this highlights a moral problem
thrown up by the Asylum system it treats
the cause of someone fleeing a country
as the basis for creating deserving and
undeserving migrants and it implies
somehow a refugee is a worthy victim
worthy of our generosity unlike economic
migrants
I'm not sure the fashion for emphasizing
Jesus as a refugee helps if I'm honest
it feels a bit of a cheap shot I mean
didn't Christ allegedly die for us all
well this sanctifying narrative and the
present system definitely incentivizes
anyone arriving to follow the script to
claim their refugees but as baroness
chakrabati uh it's so well explained
people arrive without papers without
letters from a tyrant as evidence or
what have you there is a problem and
it's um which is the systems open to
abuse
if the host authorities say they will
give Asylum to syrians inevitably
claimants from the Middle East will
claim to be syrians if the rules say
Asylum will be given to under 18s
understandably young looking
20-somethings will claim to be younger
in 2016 it was the Church of England
clerics who warned about fake
conversions from Islam to Christianity
in Nick Timothy's major report that was
published this week he notes that modern
slavery laws are being abused is now
standard advice to especially those
coming from Albania to claim their
victims of trafficking noting those
truths is not about blame I don't blame
people for trying their luck they want a
better life no accusations of scrounges
or Invaders from me but it's just simply
disingenuous to suggest that the
objectivity of the law is not being
strained when determining silence status
is so difficult
and I'm especially worried when we
Gaslight the British public who feel
that some are gaming the system and
they're right to think that and they
also believe that no matter how many
times they vote for control of the board
of borders they're being ignored at the
expense of Asylum Seekers
when most people consider the original
1951 convention for refugees the Specter
of those flying the Holocaust death
camps informed the spirit of Never Again
as many Refuge Jewish refugees were
shamefully turned away and British
citizens understand that and they
understand those fleeing the bombs and
Terror of Putin's barbaric war in
Ukraine or there are obligations to
those escaping the Taliban in
Afghanistan and so on and they are more
than welcoming well they are also
understandably upset about the 40 000
crossing the channel currently who they
know are not fleeing from the terror of
the Nazis or the Taliban but leaving
peaceful France and they are right as
well to ask British politicians about
their priorities
did my Lord see the film of the public
meeting in skegness recently called by
the mayor in response to the uh the
local Seaside hotels
yes there was a lot of hostility in that
meeting but that wasn't aimed at
refugees but at the local MP and a
frustration at a system where without
consultation Asylum seekers in their
midst would be given free accommodation
and utilities and three meals a day
while local people face the desperate
times and the brutal reality of
austerity homelessness is on the rise in
the town and the interviews with the
ex-veterans sleeping rough in skegness
also deserve our compassion and we're
heartbreaking
of course refugees aren't living in
five-star hotels I'm not suggesting that
but can we also empathize with the
citizens who can't get to see a GP or
get into a e or get medical treatment
for chronic brain when they're told that
medical services are being made
available to refugees in local hotels
dismissing the plights and aspirations
of our own citizens so well articulated
I thought by the noble baroness baroness
Stroud absolutely styled and strategy is
is just as divisive and mean spirited as
using the language of invasion this
issue requires that we do that we deploy
a full range of moral principles our
duties stretch Beyond compassion for
migrants
if we've flown the Democratic duty to
uphold the Integrity of national borders
and treat the social cohesion of settled
communities as a distasteful
inconvenient obstacle we do indeed risk
a backlash against all refugees and
migration schemes which would be
terrible in my view we need a complete
overhaul of the laws on the issue at
present who is in control
Dr Michael
Ali the former Bishop of Rochester in
his forward to the recent pamphlet three
essays on the morality of Asylum wrote
The People Smugglers can simply nullify
debating legislation and policy by
Landing people in small craft on the
beaches in Kent this cannot indefinitely
be acceptable in a democratic law
respecting Nation so I think Nick
Timothy is right that if human rights
laws of the 1951 Refugee convention
prevent us from democratically deciding
our priorities we must be prepared to
leave both if necessary
those who disagree who think that there
should be more refugees should argue for
that democratically and push that up uh
the the uh next elections list of things
to be debated well we should rather
exceeded her time
my Lord I begin very clear in my
interests as a member of your Lordships
uh justice and home Affairs committee
I'd like to begin by thanking the most
Reverend primary who once again brings
before us today a subject that allows us
to rise above the topicality of daily
politics and properly focus and think
about an important policy area my Lord
it was six years ago that I made my
maiden speech in your lordship's house
in another of the
um most reverent primaries and debate
that time on British values and if I may
I'd like to quote from the Lord
archbishop's opening remarks he said in
short we need a more beautiful and
better common narrative that shapes and
inspires us with a common purpose a
vaulting National ambition not a sense
of division and antagonism both
domestically and internationally we need
a narrative that speaks to the world of
bright hope and Not Mere optimism let
alone simple so of interest in the area
of migration my lords it seems to me
that we have reached a place wherein
lots of complete competing values and
aspirations are clashing and failing to
provide the necessary framework that can
command consensus and that common
purpose that the most reverent primates
or eloquently described in that debate
only last week we witnessed outrage in
many quarters about the number of
migrants who've entered the UK this year
for getting the enormous public support
their Wars quite rightly for the Afghan
Ukrainian and Hong Kong humanitarian
resettlement schemes however with
figures of net migration juxtaposed and
conflated with images of small boats it
will be the case as ladies still refer
to where a poll earlier this week showed
only nine percent of people thought that
immigration currently in the UK was just
right all too often the debate seems
characterized in a way that consensus
and a settled position may never be
reached I've yet to meet anyone and the
most reverent primate referred to this
who doesn't think there should be
controlled migration yes of course
government policy should be considered
and will always be challenged in your
lordship's house but if the government
can be expected to control migration and
they are after allowing more
humanitarian channels then it will have
to act to defeat the evil of people
smuggling and I'm glad to say that's a
priority of the Prime Minister in this
regard I tend to agree with the recent
policy exchange paper which Noble Lords
have already referred to uncontrolled
immigration published this week we must
be realistic my lords that the extra
humanitarian Roots many of us won't will
only gain popular and then political
consent when the small boats issue and
evil gangs have been confronted
consensus and migration issues requires
leadership if there are three principal
bucket buckets of migration that the UK
wishes to fulfill humanitarian economic
and educational each must be properly
defined and promoted to the people of
this country in each of these areas my
Lord's a consensus of support can be
built it has been done before however
this is going to require significant
improvements in the systems deployed to
control immigration as well as assurance
that the UK is proactively seeking to
improve its humanitarian and Asylum
offer humanitarian needs are only going
to increase the unhcr has identified
that 1.5 million will require more would
require Asylum or resettlement in the
coming year undoubtedly something that
leads to lack of public consensus is the
very slow processing rate of Asylum
claims by the home office that number of
no Lords have referred to I hope my
Noble friend the minister will be able
to give your Lordships reassurance in
his winding up speech that there is
going to be the kind of human and
creative investment in the home office
system to ensure Asylum
claimants are given as quick a decision
as possible the tiny numbers of Asylum
decisions presently a only cause further
distress from those for those escaping
from horrific tragedy but b means that
others see the UK as a place where a
very slow process will allow leave to
remain for a long period of time as well
as being efficient such a system must
also be humanitarian I happen to believe
that the United Kingdom does have a
proud history of humanitarian action but
almost always my Lord's at a point where
it's just a little too late and this was
something lady chakrabati referred to we
must move away from a situation where
legal resettlement schemes are reliant
on media media reports to gain public
traction to in turn ensure Public School
support for legal resettlement we have
one of the best diplomatic networks in
the world my lords surely we should have
proactive resettlement plans that do not
require horrific humanitarian
circumstances before we allow a regular
legal route to the UK yes my Lord we
will disagree in the numbers but it is
clear that the schemes we currently
introduce do not allow an organic
ability to react to humanitarian crisis
from outside of specific countries will
my Noble friend the minister outline
what work his Majesty's government is
doing with unhcr to identify regular
resettlement routes from areas of the
world like sub-Saharan sub-Saharan
Africa unless we allow such a mechanism
then can we be surprised about the large
numbers who end up in the North coast of
Africa and then onwards to the channel
in conclusion my lords it's with deep
regret I feel we currently do not seem
to have the clear consensus and
value-based values-based migration
strategy that we would want and it
should then shape policy this is the
worst of all worlds and I hope that my
Noble friend and Minister will be able
to reassure us that this new
conservative Administration is
determined to provide the leadership the
country needs both in managing migration
but also offering the humanitarian
leadership we would all design
my Lord is the most Reverend primary to
the Archbishop of Canterbury made a very
powerful speech on which I congratulate
him
he reminded us of our duty to receive
indeed welcome refugees
that as many noble Lords of Vermont
cannot be challenged
the challenge the challenge my lords is
to distinguish between those who are
genuine refugees and those who are
economic migrants and it's not an easy
thing to do
my Lord's the present situation in the
channel is extremely damaging
it's the reputation of the government
to the rule of law
to community relations and perhaps even
to confidence in our political system as
a whole
that said
a major incentive for these arrivals is
that they are now very unlikely to be
sent home
most of those whose claims fail will
join the illegal population of the UK
which runs into at least a million or
more even
and it might well include of course some
of their relatives
as a matter of fact 15 of cross-channel
Rivals in 2019 had already made a claim
elsewhere
70 percent are aged men men aged between
18 and 39.
and 98 have no passport
why because they've Destroyers to make
it more difficult to decide their case
and of course a hundred percent are
coming from a safe country
my Lord says cannot be allowed to
continue it really cannot
and we must find a way forward within
the framework of Ethics that the noble
Archbishop mentioned
my Lord's
suggestions from the Asylum Lobby if I
may call them
that we should establish safe and legal
routes
may be useful as sound bites but they
are simply unrealistic
applications would have to be made in
some Third Country
at an application center presumably run
by the British government
surely it's absolutely clear that such a
facility would be
immediately overwhelmed by applications
and any host government would say this
immediately
and that they would say that they would
be left holding the baby responsible for
the people we had rejected and and
they're just not going to go down that
route and of course none of them have
meanwhile government hurt our government
of course are in real difficulty nearly
60 of the public think that they have
lost control of our borders and
something in that
84 think that they are handling
immigration badly
yet much of the national conversation
including uh if I may say so this debate
simply does not reflect the reality of
public opinion on this issue
and here I commend the courageous speech
by baroness stole at the outset of this
debate and later the remarks of the
noble Lord Lord horn
will also fundamental issue is that the
authority of our government is being
blatantly undermined
the government is tied up in knots by
the current framework of law so it's
time perhaps that that whole framework
was re-examined
the 1951 Refugee convention so often
referred to and widely applauded
but if seldom realized that it applies
only to events in Europe not only to
those that preceded 1951.
it wasn't until 1966 that the UN
protocol widened its application to the
whole world without time limit or
geographical restriction and with very
very little public discussion at the
time
and in the ensuing half second half
century
conditions have changed enormously
throughout the world and so too has the
legal framework
it's possible now for cases to be to
include the Fatal women in some
countries of gay people and others of
persecution by factions who are not the
government
and by degrading treatment in some
circumstances
so it's important to note at this point
that both the refugee convention and the
UN protocol provide for signatories to
withdraw at 12 months notice
we need therefore I suggest my lords to
give serious consideration as to whether
This legal framework is still
appropriate
there may be cries of horror at any such
suggestion but we must recognize that a
continuation of present chaos will be
very harmful to those who themselves
need Asylum
we should therefore consider
establishing a mechanism that perhaps a
royal commission or something of that
kind to examine all options
and my Noble friend Lord Brown of Eaton
Hayward touched on that possibility and
so did baroness Fox
the overall aim would be to ensure that
the system continues to be supported by
the wider public and it's not
overwhelmed
by the huge number of claims some of
which are
unlikely to be successful
to conclude my Lord I'd like to and my
Lord I'd like to um
say a word of Welcome to the very
wide-ranging report on Asylum published
this week by the center for policy
studies
in her forward to that report the Home
Secretary wrote
the British public are fair-minded
tolerant and generous in spirit
that they're fed up with a continuing
flouting of our laws and immigration
rules so as to gain the Asylum system
my Lord's exactly said
melods are
easier to follow the noble Lord because
I've always listened to him never agreed
with him but he studies the problem very
thoroughly and I like that so I do
respect what he said and in some cases I
want to follow him uh now I'm I'm not a
I'm not a Christian I'm not only an
atheist it's much worse I'm an
economists uh and uh the question I want
to ask is
who gains from this policy we have
this we are definitely losing there's no
doubt everybody knows that as a country
UK is losing reputation and is losing
money
okay and who gains the gangsters
right now as an economist I asked most
of this question
this clearly profit to be made in
smuggling people here why because there
is a demand for coming to UK
and people are willing to pay a hefty
price
for what the gangsters charge
why can't we have that money
why don't we say okay
come to us
no problems
we were going to accommodate you women
but we will not throw you out yet and we
will give you a temporary one year or
two year pass
give the money the two thousand pounds
that you spend to us don't give it to
the gangsters
okay
I say that because it's quite clear
that the legal Roots which people use
for coming here
are so porous that people have figured
out how to game the law
so the law is clearly inadequate and we
may appoint a royal commission to find
out whether we can improve on the law
but certainly the law is
is actually not working people who
genuinely want to come here for economic
reasons and I welcome them I think they
are the only genuine people who want to
come here
obviously to pretend that they're Asylum
Seekers that they're refugees that they
are stateless or they're being
persecuted and any as of the law being
such that we have to actually then have
hearings whether they're they're right
or not they're obviously lost this
passport because they are not stupid
they know how to how to game the system
okay well we are being gamed
we are being gamed by people who are
perfectly capable of paying money to
come here
they're paying money to the crooks and
we are losing money ourselves because we
have to spend a lot of money
accommodating these people and as in
some cases people say it takes months
and years and again as a right traveling
uh president said
uh we don't allow them to work and we
should
why are we losing money each week by our
inefficiency in not being able to solve
this problem
the solution is very simple they're
going to stay here anyway
illegally
so why don't we allow them to say
legally
and and get the money ourselves I I I'm
sort of uh I've always wondered I think
there is a
in politics I'm sorry to say I hope I'm
wrong but there's a there's a political
career to be made by being hostile
uh oh these are immigrant they're
illegal and they're dirty and they're
good
they're famous people they
actually
really about the
it's a better business staying anywhere
else we should be flattered and we found
find out okay you want to come here come
here but pay a price for that because
you're going to benefit from it and
you're going to cost us something so we
want you to uh
so I think in a sense what we need to do
as many people have said rethink this
whole question of immigration
first of all I think we ought to clear
up our statistics because everybody
talks about so many Crossings and so on
bulk of the people who come here come
legally come regularly and there's no
problem
the headlines are about this both both
people and I think we really ought to
seriously compete with the gangsters and
offer ourselves the facility
you you may set up an office in Calais
or Tirana or whatever but just sense to
people there's no problem you just come
come in about coming whatever we will
run the words of ourselves we will
nationalize the gangster's business but
I think we should stop being absurd
about this and
some clarity about not worrying about
the reputation about the right to
impress or whatever it is and say who
gains from what we do we're not
controlling our borders we're just
losing money we're losing a reputation
and we'll be we're being made to look
like fools
stop being foolish
stop losing money stop losing a
reputation and play the game better than
they can play
my Lord's the quality and quantity of
contribution to this debate shows how
much the house is grateful to the
Archbishop for choosing this subject and
for introducing our debates so
inspiringly I thank you I think it was
in Sebastian hafner's wonderful Memoir
defying Hitler that I read the story of
the South London German
is rounded up Germans rounded up mainly
Jewish in 1939
taken to the Crystal Palace football
ground on route to internment on the
Isle of Man Hafner being a German was
used to German efficiency and was
surprised when the transport failed to
turn up and even more surprised when the
loudspeaker politely invited all those
sitting on the pitch to go home and come
back tomorrow please
a nice story with the uh with the
incompetence taking the edge off the
cruelty
alas it doesn't seem to work that way
now
the incompetence of our Asylum system
compounds its cruelty
just as the 1939 Roundup of those who
particularly wanted to resist Hitler was
a bit perverse
so in today's economic circumstances
it's very perverse to spend one and a
half million a day not allowing
able-bodied Asylum Seekers to take a job
and the Isle of Man was no Rwanda
and the fear of invasion then was well
founded whereas
rhetoric about Invasion now is totally
unjustified we get eight Asylum
applications a year for every hundred
thousand of us the French get more than
twice as many the Germans three times as
many appoint the Archbishop made
likely
I believe that the effects of home
office practice are a stain in our
society
but giving the benefit of the doubt I
don't believe that's deliberate I think
it's the unintended consequence of
inefficiency
consider the facts in the year to
September there were 86 000 new
applications for Asylum
including five thousand from
unaccompanied children
only sixteen thousand of the 86 000 were
decided
so the queue of those waiting for an
initial decision grew to 143 000.
in the Years October over 3 000 children
were housed in unsuitable hotel
accommodation
currently over 200 of them
placed in hotels are known to have gone
missing
that's shocking
it shames us
and it gets worse the refugee Council
where I used to be a trustee tell us
that of the 140 000 now waiting for
their cases to be considered 98 000 have
waited for sick over six months forty
one thousand between one and three years
and an astonishing ten thousand
including over 150 children have been
waiting for over five years
that's longer than internment the Isle
of Man it's shocking and it shames us
remember that we're not talking about
appealing an uh an initial decision
these numbers are just those waiting
hoping that one day the government will
get round to looking at their claim
remember too that 77 of claims are found
uh valid and accepted
plus over 50 percent of those that go to
appeal so in the main we're not talking
about fraudsters and chances more than
nine out of ten of those in the queue
will in the end be found of a valid case
a genuine and well-founded fear of
persecution they fled oppression
violence war or famine and I have to
tell the noble Lord
lordly that the the reason they've come
here is because they speak our language
they've got family here or they've heard
alas it seems not always the case that
we are still a friendly hospitable
people actually I believe that we are
but there will be a letdown by a system
which isn't deliberately callous the
home office know that the delays have no
deterrent effect but is callous in
effect because of inefficiency but that
means the problem is fixable and it is
relatively easy to see what we need to
do I have two questions for the minister
first when will the government implement
the recommendations on Asylum casework
made over a year ago by the independent
Chief Inspector of borders and
immigration why not streamline the
system
and second isn't it time to set up a
dedicated task force to clear the
backlog prioritizing the most vulnerable
and those who waited longest it really
isn't rocket science
if given a clear ministerial instruction
the admirable permit sector at the home
office could reallocate the resources
tomorrow
yes we should also shut down the scandal
of small boat Channel Crossings and that
too soluble people wouldn't risk their
lives if they had the option of a safe
official route at present if you are
from a crane unless you're from a crane
uh Afghanistan or a unhcr camp in Syria
there is no safe route as the Archbishop
pointed out you can only ask for Asylum
when you get here and we won't give you
a visa to come here if it's Asylum you
seek catch 22. why not a humanitarian
Visa
why not process applications in France
as the French keep suggesting
but getting back to our values means
tackling the backlog I repeat that I
believe it it Springs from inertia not
malign intent but sins of a mission are
sometimes the worst these problems are
all soluble let's solve them and as so
many in this debate have said while the
people wait in the queue let's allow
them to work it would be good for them
for the ex-jacker for the economy and
for our consciences
my lords I'm grateful to the most
Reverend primate for this debate which
follows neatly from last year's
archbishop's debate which was on freedom
of speech we had a terrible period in
the last decade of Oppression of freedom
of speech on this issue you couldn't
talk about immigration or Asylum as it
was synonymous with being racist for the
overwhelming majority of course it
wasn't it was more to do with pressure
on school places GPS appointments
pre-pandemic housing and depressed wages
affecting ordinary working folk at that
time who are and were then affected much
more so by these issues than the middle
classes a wholeheartedly welcomed the
recognition by of this by the most
Reverend primary which is a change of
position in the leadership of the Church
of England who sadly in the run-up to
the 2016 referendum did not Champion
these communities barring of course some
comments from the bishop of Burnley
I count myself in the only blessed by
migration category I glanced at my
Christmas Christmas gift spreadsheet
British Nigerians British trinidadians
Singapore Chinese British Singapore
Chinese and Hong Kong Chinese British
Eritrean and Syrian
the latter two families have educated me
on the issues of Asylum and I'm very
grateful but I hope briefly to make just
some Ordinary People points
it is unclear to the ordinary person why
thousands of albanians are claiming
asylum in the UK despite the noble lady
hamway's comments what are they fleeing
it may be just a communication issue but
it needs a dressing as do the fears that
the landmark modern slavery legislation
is being misused
as his Majesty's loyal opposition as of
yesterday has joined his Majesty's
government in saying you should
fast-track claims where there is a where
a claim is manifestly unfounded could my
Noble friend the minister please confirm
that the only matter therefore left in
dispute is whether you designate a whole
country for such consideration and still
comply with the 1951 convention I do
hope that the most Reverend primate is
right that we can introduce something
akin to striking out a claim as happens
in The Civil Court where there's no
reasonable Prospect of a claim but I
would be interested to know if the most
Reverend primates and my Noble friend
has any view on what appeal rights would
or would not be appropriate laudable
aims could be strangled by necessary
judicial procedures
as a lawyer my Lord I enjoyed reading
the unhcr document legal considerations
regarding claims for international
protection made in the context of the
adverse effects of climate change and
disasters
but it's hard to understand why if your
territory disappears literally as what
could happen to the Maldives or Pacific
island States you're not automatically a
refugee
convoluted arguments like this one
you're the victim of a flood caused by
climate change but you're also part of a
religious group that was not given Aid
by your government so you had to flee
the borders and you needed Refuge this
will take up valuable time and money
when these kind of claims reach our
tribunals is it not time my lords to
consider a separate convention in
addition to the refugee convention on
the issue of refugees due to climate
change rather than straining the
interpretation of the 1951 treaty
I would be interested in him in my Noble
friends view on this but I would also
caution the noble and landed Lord Lord
Brown and my most Reverend primary on
reopening the treaty itself unless you
can guarantee the same post-second world
war consensus on this which I very much
doubt
turning my lords though to Ukraine
we are rightly proud of our response to
this crisis I think it's over 125 000
people are here they're not refugees
that's that fudgy legal distinction like
the Hong Kong migration under though the
Ukraine family scheme there was a very
broad definition of family members who
could join you if you were already in
the UK and qualified niece nephew cousin
mother-in-law or father-in-law even
grandparents in law and brother and
sister-in-law
but on this issue I would like my Noble
friends assurance that the home office
is proactive and meets with fcdo around
the areas of geographical instability
my Lord I think I'm correct in saying
that mercifully there have only been
sporadic conflicts in Nations where
British citizens have Heritage recent um
conflict in Ethiopian Eritrea but that
might change in February of next year we
all hope and pray and I'm sure the most
Reverend primate is praying for
successful Nigerian elections and we
hope that the nation holds together
but there are serious concerns the
Europa tribe of the West have already
petitioned the United Nations to
supervise a referendum to split
and it's said that the ebo of the 1960s
biafran East separatist War looked to do
the same rarely are those kind of
matters settled peacefully this my Lord
is a nation of conservatively estimated
of 250 million people many with family
here in the UK
those British citizens with Nigerian
Heritage might rightly expect the same
generous definition of family ties in
Nigeria as the Ukrainian scheme
please could my Noble friends assure me
that the home office is considering
policy for this kind of eventuality
thinking through the eventualities to
ensure that our policy should the worst
happen is racially just
finally on reading many of the reports
for this debate I am concerned that we
are repeating the mistakes the person I
I note the comments made by the noble
lady ladies stole
whilst residents in the whilst residents
in the UK especially ordinary working
people are not fleeing for their lives
they are deeply affected by these issues
as I as I say more than most of us here
in your lordship's house of course if we
forget again ordinary working folk I
fear that we will not build a home
together as the late Lord SATs so wisely
advised us to do and we may not have a
referendum on the issue as a necessary
release valve
my Lord
the end is nigh
um that's possibly for lunch but not for
all refugees
and then I start with the remarks of the
unfortunate remarks of the senior lady
in waiting last week
she was asking a visitor who are you and
where are you from
and perhaps the questions were not
entirely innocent
we all I think have a tendency to
inquire about other people
it's a sort of defense against the
unknown
and the other person may read the
defense as a form of attack or even
racism
but my Lord it is not racism it is
ignorance and fear it can happen to any
of us we just have to try harder to get
to know each other our upbringing and
training surely demanded
and the church as Lord Lily said
calls it who is my neighbor
and it's a perennial question the answer
is of course everyone including those
tens of millions of migrants and Asylum
Seekers who a time seems to be coming
towards us
we have a reputation for welcoming
refugees as being said and recently we
have gratefully received compliments
from refugees about this country
there are many reasons why people want
to come
albanians seem to be the most
self-assured even they may not have
those smart number plates anymore
they have no real reason to leave
Albania except that they can earn so
much more exactly in the UK can we blame
them
she is well I'm very tempted by Lord
desire's suggestion
the numbers have recently felt
overwhelming we must accept that we need
to congratulate the government on some
of the resettlements in schemes which
have at least secured more orderly
arrivals the HCR Syrian scheme that only
after much pressing from Lord dubs and
others in the house has had some success
the Ukrainian scheme is not really
equivalent but it's undoubtedly worked
well until now
with the scale of the Afghan Exodus
last year it took Everyone by surprise
as certainly the government
uh
nobody could say that was a satisfactory
operation
but there were some remarkable Rescue
Stories including lady Kennedy's
evacuation of women judges
today there are many women in hiding
from the Taliban who would or should
qualify for resettlement
so may I ask the minister what is
happening to these resettled schemes why
are they falling short
but at the other end of the scale there
are many Asylum Seekers outside these
schemes especially those living on
charity or detained indefinitely
awaiting removal
and in many cases these are from
war-torn countries like Sudan and
Somalia on the margin of the convention
fleeing drought and poverty as well as
persecution
they struggle to claim Asylum having
very few documents
not always for the reasons just given
and little evidence of their past life
and treatment
Lord dubs describe the amazing work
of the charities
to toil
to make people's lives more credible
more tolerable
these are church members they're lawyers
experts in torture ngos campaigners of
every kind who condemn the treatment
that's being meted out to these refugees
the waiting list for courts are
lengthening just as they are in
hospitals
almost one-fifth of those claiming
Asylum are children under 18 including
many who are wrongly treated as adults
and Lord Tasman and others have
mentioned that for Helen Bamba
Foundation a very respected body
concerned that too many young children
kept for long periods in hotels without
proper care home opposite sometimes
appears to be seizing up
every
peer has admitted this unable to cope
with numbers lacking the necessary
skills and the successive government has
been called a shambles
so
this is a national crisis
isn't it time for more cooperation
between the political parties
and I'm also concerned that funding has
been diverted from the aid program but
that's another subject
I hope the government the minister will
respond to the Practical suggestions
that unhcr itself put forward last
February 21 to improve registration and
screening avoid where possible the
unpleasant side of forced removal and
inadequate protection
why are they not making more use of
schemes which are still behind
pre-pandemic levels
so is the answer to deter or restrict
refugees
possibly
but that hasn't worked either
we've talked about real and accessible
safe routes
which I don't think even amnesty is
right about that
what are the Alternatives can the
minister present so
um there are some utterly wicked
traffickers as we've heard
but returning to the
Church
I do sincerely thank the most reverent
primate for inviting us to hear he's
very cogent pre-Christmas reflections
um we've also heard three Splendid
maidens
and we've heard some personal
experiences of peers and I especially
recommend in her absence lady Nicholson
talking about the Aziz very movingly
the the Archbishop may think as I do
that the anglicans
could further improve our rather dismal
attitude to strangers
diversity is now the cover word but I
won't go into all that Perhaps Perhaps
the church could do more to include
other religions in prayers in this house
for example
we need to do more work on our own
church services some of us are still
singing old lines like lands of the East
arise he is your brightest mourn or
worse than that or Heathen lands of fire
thick Darkness Brutus yet the neighbor
Lord could bring his comments to a close
you have exceeded the second time
but I am grateful for the whips for
allowing me to speak or both parties for
allowing me to speak in in the Gap
um and I have to first of all start by
thanking the uh the most reverent
prelude for opening this debate on this
on this particular issue I also
congratulate the no barriers twyford and
the noble Lord sahota and on their
Maiden speeches I have to apologize to
the right Reverend pellet um Bishop of
Lester that I missed his uh
um is made in speech um the irony was I
popped out for uh it was time to pray
um I'm sure that I really lost on him
I'd also like to thank um my Noble
Fender um the baroness barrage for
mentioning the bishop of Burnley
um the bishop and Bernie and I were best
friends at school and when we were in
detention uh 40 odd years ago little did
we think that one of us would end up a
bishop in the Church of England and the
other would end up a member of the House
of Lords not really a great incentive
for school children to behave well
um now on this on this particular issue
the reason I Rise as an academic and as
someone who was a head of research at a
think tank How would did I write about
this issue because there are lots of
challenges as the son of an immigrant
who actually came on two big boats one
from Guyana to Trinidad and then one
from Trinidad to the UK in the early
1950s of course my heart says we should
let everyone in we should you know we
should be open to the whole world but my
head says we can't let everyone in and
the difficulty here is where do we draw
the line and this has troubled me for
some time where do we draw the line we
draw a line all very differently and
this has been a struggle to try and
write where we draw the line
um and so I really think we first of all
we have to look at the two issues I
suppose seeking Asylum and those seeking
to come here on immigration and on
Asylum of course we have to open our
hearts to people who are suffering
terribly uh in in the in the rest of the
world but we also have to ask some
questions how do we differentiate
between genuine Asylum Seekers and
process them as quickly as possible to
get them into British society and to
contribute in a positive way but those
who fail how do we make sure we have
tough love with them and we send them
away in a most humanitarian and
appropriate way possible despite people
campaigning perhaps for them to stay but
also we have to think about sometimes
the cause of these people wanted to come
to this country and we have to think do
we have a moral responsibility in some
of our foreign Adventures which has led
to our refugees from some of these
countries and as part of that do we have
some moral responsibility to Bear even
if we can't let them let them all in and
how do we speed up processing and I want
to thank my Noble friend the minister
for answering my written questions on
the government plans to speed up process
and I hope my neighbor will share some
of those thoughts there
um but how do we make sure we return
people as quickly as possible now on the
other part of immigration those who want
to come and make a better life in this
country as my parents did I am pleased
now that we seem to have a more a fairer
system that we've left the EU that we no
longer give priorities a mostly white
Europeans over mostly non-white
non-europeans and we treat everyone
equally but can we have a point system
that is dynamic that we identify the
skills gaps in this country and we and
we are quite clear and transparent with
people these are the skills we are
looking for and encourage them to come
and can we perhaps use technology and AI
for example to scan vacancy boards and
to give those those vacancies higher
points so people can come here I also
agree that we should look at legal
groups of migration outside this country
but what are the unintended consequences
of that can we change our language so we
actually are welcoming and we understand
why people come and not treat everyone
as Invaders can we work internationally
can we um can we find those clear rules
can we have a dynamic point system could
we have a system of compassion but can
we be quite clear that those who want to
come here and work and we have those
gaps we we would welcome them and those
who are fleeing and genuinely fleeing we
will help you as much as we can in
conjunction with International Partners
in conjunction with civil society and in
conjunction with International
organizations and let's hope that the
government whichever government and
future governments can come up with a
more compassionate policy so that most
of us can share it thank you
so this has been an excellent very
important and timely debate on the eve
of the noble baroness lady chakrabarty
pointed out of Human Rights Day from
these benches we very much welcome this
vital opportunity to reflect upon the
impact of government Asylum policy the
most reverent primate the Archbishop of
Canterbury is to be greatly
congratulated on instigating this debate
and the number of speakers shows the
volume of interest in the topic and is a
tribute to him
the most Reverend primate said
among many other things
quote a compassionate Asylum system does
not mean open borders but a disposition
of generosity and a Readiness to welcome
those whose need is genuine and which we
are able to meet
it is one that has confidence to reject
this the shrill narratives that all who
come to us for help should be treated as
liars scroungers and less than fully
human
I think I agree very strongly with those
words and indeed his whole speech and
with his View and that of the Bishops
collectively that the government's
policy on shipping Asylum Seekers to
remand Rwanda is quote an immoral policy
that shames Britain
the only thing I'm not persuaded about I
think rather like the noble baroness
lady Burridge is the wisdom of opening
up the refugee convention for Amendment
um even if I accept the point about new
causes like climate change I fear that
revising the refugee convention could be
a Pandora's Box inviting that sliding
and I think the words of the noble Lord
Lord green put me on notice about that I
would also comment that trafficking is
already an international crime under EU
law that the UK government refused to
take part in that tick and directive
though confusingly I noticed they
revoked it recently anyway
which is confusing
the um right Reverend probably the
bishop of life is still the noble Lord
Lord sahota Noble baroness lady twycross
all made important and valuable Maiden
speeches they did try cross rightly
praise the community response to Afghan
refugees as well as recalling her own
family's diverse origin I can relate to
her fate of being too opinionated for
the Civil Service I only lasted 15
months for the same reason
recalled the impressive history of his
family in both India and the UK and this
and quote the slings and arrows of
racial discrimination
he deplored the limbo and exploitation
into which Asylum Seekers sink and the
cost of that to society and the public
bus as well as to individuals
the right reverent prelate the bishop of
Leicester recalled how the city of
Leicester has thrived as a city of
migration as well as his own history we
are all he says pilgrims in a foreign
land
my mother my own mother was born in
Dublin which makes me a joke National so
I have a tinge of that
the noble Lord Lord dubs his
contribution on Refugee issues is second
to none I congratulate his 90th uh him
on his 90th birthday he looks
embarrassed at that but um he's a
splendid colleague on the joint
committee on human rights so we're both
about to be chucked up by rotation only
I appreciate it
um the noble lady baroness the no
baroness lady Nicholson talked of the
terrible plight of the yazidis and um
that going back to the noble Lord Jabs
he he said that
um our Australian policy tested who we
are as a country so agree with that and
he recalled of course the Kinder
transport Noble Lord Lord Cormac spoke
of the sugar nose but government policy
and the language around it seems to junk
that Heritage displaying a growing
politicization playing to populist
nationalism a shirking of our share of
global responsibility and are not a
failure to uphold international human
rights and Refugee law and to set an
example of International Leadership and
partnership including through
cooperation with our European neighbors
and the noble Lord Hane spoke on those
themes
I'm sorry that the noble lady baroness
stole and and others as my Noble friend
baroness Hanley noted conflated economic
migration which government has full
control over but has allowed to increase
and flows of refugees
the government's policy is one not a
shelter but of deterrence which the
nationality and borders act 2022 has in
several ways that violate international
human rights and Asylum law in trench as
a noble Lord Lord Kerr said the
incompetence compounds the cruelty
measures
punish and penalize people for seeking
Asylum by the only means that is
available to them usually a dangerous
Journey controlled by dangerous
organized criminals the noble Lord Lord
Griffiths told us that only 13 of Asylum
Seekers who go missing are ever found
but all of this is not prevented the
escalation in the rhetoric of the Home
Secretary in her immigration Minister
Robert genre they throw around terms
like threat Invasion and illegal about
largely vulnerable and frightened people
seeking Asylum
as others have said the Home Secretary
called them Invaders barely 24 hours
after a fire bomb attack upon people
seeking Asylum detained at the Western
jet fall site in Dover
I certainly agree with the noble Lord
Lord come out on the need to change
language around the issue
so this debate takes place days after
the Home Secretary welcomed and
apparently endorsed as vital and
necessary a collection of proposals
including pulling out of the European
convention on human rights and the
refugee convention and proposing
indefinite detention for arrivals put
forward in a report for the center for
policy Studies by Nick Timothy former
advisor to Theresa May these Reckless
proposals elicited a public denunciation
from unhcr saying they were based on
quote critical factual and legal errors
unhcr pointed out again there is no such
thing as an illegal Asylum seeker and
the noble baroness lady chakrabarty also
made this point a far better report than
Nick Timothy's one came in October from
the Oxford Refugee study center the
refugee Council the NGO Unbound and no
the noble baronet lady Stroud of the
Legato Institute whose excellent speech
I am delighted to have listened to today
lady strategy of course did so much in
the debates on the nationality and
borders Bill to advocate for the right
of Asylum Seekers to work
this is because it is a win-win policy
on every level including self-respect
self-support and fairness to taxpayers
and I think that's the answer to the
noble lady baroness Fox who talked about
people complaining of of of generosity
to Asylum Seekers they're not allowed to
support themselves and give back
um such a policy would also help address
our acute shortage of Labor and as well
as providing one of the keys to
successful integrate integration but the
government stubbornly refuses it to
refuses it and no doubt will again today
and I look forward very much to the
report of the commission chaired by the
noble Lord Lord Carlisle on integration
the contrast between the two reports I
have mentioned could not be greater one
is rooted in fear and dislike the other
on Hope and opportunity
the second report in which lady Stroud
played a role says that quote Refugee
policy should be a strategic priority
for the UK and that it can and should be
a source of national Unity as it has in
the past for both conservative and
labor-led government
I am pleased to see that the Bill of
Rights bill also known as the rights
removal bill which seeks to destroy the
Human Rights Act has been de-prioritized
by the Prime Minister but my pleasure is
tempered by the fact that the apparent
reason is to make more space for a bill
to overhaul the broken Asylum system and
combat the so-called Channel boats
crisis but the Asylum Seekers Asylum
system is only broken as my Noble friend
baroness hamri called it at night Noble
friend Brown is how many called it
exclusionary and unworkable because
excessive conservative home secretaries
have failed to get to grips with what
ought to be a manageable manageable
administrative task of establishing
through a fair and efficient
determination of claims whether people
are refugees and sending back those who
are not we received seventy thousand
Asylum applications in the year to
September 2022. that is a fair number
but far less than France or Germany and
it should not overwhelm the home office
and other Noble Lords including my Noble
friend Lord Roberts and the right
Reverend pallet the bishop of Durham
have cited the backlog at figures so I
don't need to repeat this sorry tale
just to note the the the the effect
um that has on physical and mental
health is dire is the right reverent
primate said control has become cruelty
staggering inefficiencies by successive
governments trap people in limbo at
incredible expense in the system for
years unable to build a life or to
contribute to society this is the worst
of all possible worlds in such a ways
but rather than prioritize clearing that
back clock the complications
differential treatment and inner
miscibility rules in the nationality and
borders act are likely to add further
delays can the noble Lord the minister
tell me what assessment the home office
has made on the impact of the
inadmissibility rules which provide a
new sort of of red tape is on the
prospect for reducing the back clock and
as the right reverent the bishop of York
said we have a dysfunctional Asylum
system that threatens our social
cohesion
I have a particular interest in family
reunion because I stated the latest
version of this private members Bill
through the house recently taking up the
Baton from my friend Noble friend lady
hamway the rules are far too restrictive
for instance not allowing even unmarried
daughters who are 19 or early 20s from
somewhere like Afghanistan to join their
parents siblings to be reunited or in
particular children to sponsor family
members so those children have to remain
alone lonely and vulnerable the right
reverent pro at the bishop of Durham
referred to this topic
child refugees are getting a raw deal
all round as a noble lord lord of
Carlisle describes and the home office
place is placed at nearly 3 300 children
and in hotels in the age of October 2022
with no lawful bases and outside the
child welfare and protection system of
local authorities meaning that
opportunities to protect children from
trafficking have been missed
can the noble or the minister set out
the Department's plan to end the use of
hotels particularly for other company to
sign them seeking children it's the
right Reverend the bishop of Chelmsford
highlighted the housing is an important
feature of integration
no Lord Lord Sam which noted the scandal
of money being diverted from the aid
budget to the home office
my lords the results of the government's
failed deterrence policy have been
disastrous for all parties except
organized criminals as the global Lord
Lord Desai pointed out Smugglers
traffickers and other abusers are
thriving they Thrive because governments
including sadly our present one refuse
or fail to take the responsibilities to
provide fair and efficient Asylum
systems
and I would say to Noble the noble lady
Fox as an efficient system would into
Alia identify and remove those who don't
qualify
expanding safe regular accessible
Pathways for refugees to travel to the
UK including their expanded family
reunion and humanitarian visas no blood
Lord stress would and and probably
processing on French soil as the noble
Lord Lord Cormac said and greater
resettlement as the noble Lord Lord
McInnis spoke of all of these would
offer real alternatives to dangerous
irregular Journeys my Lord's the debate
today has provided numerous ideas for
the government to improve our Asylum
System including instead of being stuck
in the disastrous state that it
currently resides
my lords it's a pleasure to follow
baroness ludford my lords I'd like to
open by thanking the uh most Reverend
primate the Archbishop of Canterbury for
initiating this debate I think it's been
a a remarkable debate and a memorable
debate
um his information I've emailed uh his
speech to my wife who's currently on a
train to Scotland she's just read it and
she thought he was a magnificent speech
um my Lord
um
the um I also want to congratulate my
Noble friends awareness tricross and
Lord sahota I wrote down the my Noble
friend baroness Craig cry cross said she
had six former bosses in this house and
I also note that because of her role in
the GLA
um where she is really used to being in
the eye of the storm she seems to me to
be exceptionally well qualified to be a
member of this house
uh I also uh wrote down a comment from
my Noble friend Lord sahota sahota he
said what he said is he wants the best
deal in the market for our fellow human
beings and I thought that was the theme
for his whole uh his whole speech and I
work I work him into our house and of
course I also welcome Noble Lord and the
right Reverend the bishop of Leicester
who I thought gave a moving speech about
the situation in Leicester and how
Leicester has benefited from migrating
communities
my lords it's common to hear
um and we have heard it in today's
debate the proud history of our country
in welcoming those in need of safety
um and it's be we have seen in recent
years uh the generosity of the British
people in response to the invasion of
Ukraine
we must always be aware of what we're
talking about when we're talking about
Asylum we're talking about people
fleeing Horrors in situations we cannot
imagine and making decisions we hope
never to have to make for our own
families
we in the opposition I believe need to
be careful in our rhetoric and we need
the government to be honest and careful
too in the language it uses we must not
conflate economic migration with those
traveling without a well-founded fear of
persecution persecution with those who
are traveling to the UK to flee torture
war and persecution these people are
asking the UK to provide a place of
safety and that was the central point of
the noble lady baroness pressure when
she made her intervention
so Molly my Lord's what we need is a
responsible and consistent policy making
the uh principles of the unhcr have been
uh referred to a number of times in this
debate
um they are firstly strengthening and
Expediting the decision-making process
ensuring that those without well-founded
claims are returned to their own
countries stepping up cooperation with
European neighbors and expanding safe
regular Pathways for Refugee refugees to
travel to the UK to offer real
alternatives to dangerous and irregular
Journeys
into it and the noble lord of the
Archbishop added to this with uh
introducing some form of triaging system
to try and expedite that process
but unfortunately my lords that's not
what we've seen from recent home
secretaries from the party opposite
my Lord's to turn briefly to the um the
issues which we have seen under this
government we've spent 140 million
pounds on Rwanda and as my Noble friend
Lord Brown said this is really just a
symbolic symbolically tough policy that
has been completely ineffective
uh we also haven't seen a commitment
from ministers who will not be uh of of
who will not be considered for a flight
to Rwanda we have repeatedly asked um
whether the ministers will commit that
people from Ukraine will not be sent to
our window or the girls and women's who
have fled here from Iran for example
will they is that there's no commitment
that they will not be sent to our Wonder
either
um and of course we have the back clock
and a number of noble laws have referred
to the figures in November 2022 about
150 000 people were still waiting for
initials initial decision with that
nearly a hundred thousand waiting over
six months and the refugee councils had
offered a stark comparison to 10 years
ago when they're only about 13 000
people waiting we must it must be
recognized that the backlog has
increased more dramatically than the
number of claims and as mentioned by the
Archbishop the backlog in cases has
increased by 305 percent in the last few
five years and these are figures from
The Institute of government
my Lord this is an operational failure
and it is the root of many of the
problems the system is facing today of
those who traveled by small boat in boat
in 2021 only four percent of the claims
have been processed as of November
the nationality and borders act far from
addressing these problems has baked them
in with firstly an inadmissibility
clause which had six months delay onto
cases but didn't deliver safe return as
safe returns agreement with our closest
neighbors secondly differentiation
policies which will require some Asylum
Seekers to have their claims repeatedly
reassessed even when they've found to
have been a well-founded reason for
seeking Asylum and thirdly restrictions
on access to family reunion routes which
will push more people into taking
extremely dangerous Journeys to try and
reach their loved ones
my Lord's turning to safeguarding we've
seen the scale of the safeguarding
problems in manston we've also heard
from Noble Lord Lord Kerr on the and
other Noble Lords about children who
have gone missing from the care of the
government and care of various local
authorities can the minister say
something about what action is being
taken to try and increase the
safeguarding for children who are in
this uh extremely difficult situation so
my lords what will actually make a
difference well firstly speeding up
Asylum decisions so people are not left
in in limbo and we don't have the
spiraling costs of hotels and
overcrowding in in our reception systems
secondly safe routes including access to
family reunion I noticed the point and I
have been following what baroness
lordford and baroness hamway have done
on this matter
of course International cooperation
which is the heart of any any solution
to this problem tackling criminal gangs
they of course are the ones acting
illegally taking advantage of people in
Desperate situations and making profits
misery although I have to say I didn't
agree with my former Noble friend Lord
Desai and his solution to this problem
um it needs to be said that the labor
party would set up a new dedicated sale
at the national Prime agency to work
cross-border to crack down on the
criminal gangs and would seek new
arrangements with France Belgium and
other European countries on returns and
family reunion and the labor party would
also Fast Track returns to designated
safe countries like Albania as other
Noble Lords have noted
my lords We Believe safe fruits are a
genuinely powerful alternatives to stop
people being pushed into the hands of
the people's snugglers and we think the
government should look at this route and
open his mind to this possibility of
reducing the current state of the crisis
my lords I think I need to acknowledge
that this is a complex and emotive issue
and it's a fast-changing issue which the
government needs to build on the history
of of receiving people in very difficult
circumstances we've heard lots of very
emotive and uh powerful examples of this
over the years and in conclusion I would
just say to the
um right primet the Archbishop of
Canterbury that I live in Southwest
London in Wandsworth and we also in
Wandsworth welcomed many huguenots and
in fact in the coat of arms of Warren
the Wandsworth Barren Council are the
tears of the ones worth of the
huguenotes who came to our
um came to our Borough and they are
recognized in many parts of the borough
so um it is a source of Pride for my
part of London
I want to thank the most Reverend
primate for leading the debate and
initiating a constructive Dialogue on
this important topic
I would also like to thank Noble Lords
on all sides of the house for their
insightful contributions
first though I would like especially to
welcome our three new members
and to thank them for their opening
contributions today
first the right Reverend or Bishop of
Leicester who's currently spearheading
the shaped by God together process
within the Leicester diocese helping
each Parish better to live out their
everyday faith in their communities
baroness twycross
has been a notable Force for change in
the health sector through her work with
diabetes UK and action against food
poverty
including calling for London to become a
zero hunger City
and I would also like to agree with
baroness twycross on her Point regarding
the great work of the London fire
brigade
and would like to refer to back to the
debate we had yesterday
concerning the culture of the fire
service in which many noble laws have
spoken today appeared
over the past two decades Lord sahota
has been tireless in serving the Telford
Community while it's also finding time
to run a business with his family Lord
sahota is the only seek on the benches
in this house and I know our debates
here will be richer with Lord sahota
baroness twycross and the Lord Bishop
my apologies
I I also share the sentiment of my Noble
uh by of Lord sahota and the Lord Bishop
of Leicester in hoping that their
elevation uh will be an omen for the
success of the English football team on
Saturday
the um
the further point that as a fairly
recent entrant to the house myself
that you will have noticed today is that
there's a tendency in this house for
those Noble Lords asking questions in
question time to make speeches and those
Noble Lords in debates when they're
meant to make speeches ask questions
so I I will ask for The house's
Indulgence in that I'm not able to
answer all the questions that I've been
asked by an overlords today but I will
endeavor to answer as many as possible
and I'm sure that those that I don't
answer Noble Lords will convert into
written questions in due course
I I would also like to thank uh baroness
Nicholson for her particularly
heart-wrenic history of the of the
yazidi position and welcome her special
guest to the house today
my lords it's no secret that the UK's
Asylum system has of late come under
severe strain
this year we have seen around 40 000
people arriving by small boats
around 100 500 individuals are currently
on Asylum support
the cost of accommodating Asylum seekers
in hotels has reached more than 5
million pounds a day
clearly something has got to change
the government has been clear on its
priorities
namely first tackling small boat
irregular arrivals by encouraging claims
to be made in the first safe country and
deterring unnecessary dangerous Journeys
to the UK
second alleviating pressures on
accommodation including by tackling
lengthy stays in processing centers
whilst of course taking the safety and
Welfare of those in our care extremely
seriously
thirdly delivering our migration and
economic development partnership with
Rwanda
and finally providing
safe and legal routes for people in need
of protection and combating
the Asylum application backlogs
and in doing that we will seek to
streamline the Asylum decision-making
process
so turning first to safer legal roots
while we are clearly grappling with
significant challenges the UK has
maintained our long and proud record of
welcoming refugees and people in need of
protection through various resettlement
schemes
under the 1951 convention people should
claim asylum in the first safe country
which they reach that is the fastest
route to safety
whilst we know there are many people in
difficult situations around the world
the UK cannot possibly accommodate
everyone who might wish to come here as
the noble Prelude identified in his
speech
we have adopted a proactive stance in
responding to world events in the wake
of Russia's appalling aggression we
introduced the Ukraine family scheme and
the homes for Ukraine scheme
since January 2022 these schemes have
received a total of 220 225
000 applications of which
85.8 percent
were granted that's 189
131 positive grants
and I'd like to thank the noble Earl for
his Commendation of the efforts of the
department in relation to those schemes
we continue to welcome people through
the existing Global UK resettlement
scheme Community sponsorship mandate
resettlement scheme and the Afghan
resettlement schemes
the government's Refugee resettlement
schemes are focused on those with the
greatest need
as determined by the UN Refugee agency
the unhcr has well-established
procedures and submission categories for
identifying and resettling the most
vulnerable refugees
the UK's Refugee resettlement schemes
aimed to do exactly what the noble Lord
Lord horeham has pointed out to bring
those to the UK who are considered
refugees as per the unhcr's criteria
since its expansion in September 2015 a
total of 20 103 people have been
resettled in the UK through the
vulnerable persons resettlement scheme
or vprs across more than 300 local
authorities
alongside the vprs we ran the Gateway
Protection Program which has resettled
over 9
939 people
the vprs closed in February 2021 and is
succeeded by the global United Kingdom
resettlement scheme which has since
creation settled some
1882 people
we have also resettled over 800 through
the community sponsorship scheme since
it began in 2016.
I would like to respond to baroness
Hamley who asked what the actual number
of Afghans assisted is
the Afghan citizens resettlement scheme
or acrs was formally opened in January
of this year with Pathways 2 and 3
launched in June and this will provide
support for up to 20 000 people affected
by events in Afghanistan
this is in addition to those coming
under the Afghanistan relocation and
assistance package
operation pitting was the largest UK
military evacuation since the second
world war and saw around fifteen
thousand individuals evacuated to the UK
some of whom were the first to be
settled under the acrs
in the year following the evacuation
around 6 000 people have arrived in the
UK viring neighboring countries under a
combination of arap and the acrs pathway
one
the number of vulnerable and at-risk
individuals granted leave under pathway
one now stands at over 6 300.
therefore
to say we have not welcomed anyone
through the Afghan citizens resettlement
scheme and the Afghan relocations and
assistance policy is simply not true
in addition to these routes the
government provides a safe and legal
route to bring families together through
its family reunion policy this allows a
partner or spouse and dependent children
to join their Refugee family members in
the UK if they form part of the family
unit before the sponsor fled their
country
turning them to Asylum decision making
which has been a topic of many speeches
amongst in your Noble in your lordship's
house
we agree with the point that many have
that we agree with the point that many
have made today that it is unacceptable
that there are so many outstanding
claims awaiting a decision
the Asylum system has been under
mounting pressure for several years
increased and sustained intake
and a growing number of people awaiting
a decision have led to significant
delays in concluding Asylum claims
current efforts are focused on deciding
older claims High harm cases and cases
with extreme vulnerability such as
mental health child cases new claims and
those in receipt of support since the
nationality and borders act came into
force on the 28th of June of this year
I would like to thank my Noble friend
Lord horeham for his insightful comments
about the impact of excessive
immigration on communities
prioritization is the answer
we cannot favor those who can afford to
pay the people Smugglers over other
Asylum Seekers
I would also like to thank the most
Reverend primate for his suggestion of a
treat of triaging Asylum claims and
removing those who are not going to be
granted Asylum immediately in order to
speed up decision making also an idea uh
canvas by Lord Carlisle of bury you
in practice however while we Endeavor to
remove individuals as quickly as
possible delays to removal occur due to
legal barriers such as fresh claims
further representations modern slavery
claims and judicial reviews
all of which must be considered before
removal
before he leaves a consideration of how
to improve the working of the system
could you tell us what has happened to
the recommendations from the reviewer
the independent review 13 months ago
yes yes those um considerations are
currently being studied in the
department and will feed into future
policy on this issue
where an individual's claim is
unsuccessful they would need to be
removed to their country of citizenship
or another destination where they would
be accepted
it was apparent that there was a tension
between the suggestion of the Archbishop
of York and the most reverent primate
the Archbishop of Canterbury on whether
we should extend our Ukrainian policies
to all nationalities
as the Archbishop of Canterbury rightly
noted it is of course not immoral to
have a limit or restrictions on
migration
whilst we sympathize with the many
individuals who are in difficult
situations around the world the United
Kingdom simply cannot help everyone who
may like to come to this country
we have introduced the Asylum
transformation program which aims to
bring the system back into balance and
to modernize it
it focuses on increasing productivity by
streamlining simplifying and digitizing
processes to speed up Asylum decision
making and increase efficiency and
output
since the program was established in the
summer of 2021 a number of positive
steps have been taken
more decision makers have been recruited
alongside steps to keep experienced
staff in post
we have also tested a range of
initiatives aimed at reducing the time
it takes to interview and decide Asylum
claims
changes in recent trials have doubled
the number of decisions made per week
and we're looking to roll these
initiatives initiatives out Nationwide
as a result
my lords this is undoubtedly a
significant task
but I can assure the house that efforts
to address the backlog and alleviate the
current pressures will continue in
earnest
I hope this can assure and the noble
Lord Lord McKinnis my Noble friend that
the changes we're making will fix the
issues with the Asylum decision-making
process
many of those arriving in the UK claim
to be children and don't have clear
evidence like a passport to back this up
making is very challenging and the
current process is very subjective and
can be disputed in long and expensive
legal proceedings
the United Kingdom typically receives
over 3 000 Asylum claims from alleged
unaccompanied Asylum seeking children
per year
many of those arriving in the UK who
claim to be children
do not have evidence between September
between 2016 and September 2022 there
were 7 357 Asylum cases where age was
disputed
in the subsequent resolution some half
that's
3696 individuals were in fact found to
be adults
and whether a claimant is an adult or a
child they're referred to a local
Authority's Social Services Department
for a careful case law compliant age
assessment and they will be treated as a
child until a decision on their age is
made
I don't need to remind
Noble Lords that one of the consequences
of an adult
being treated as a child is that this
has the potential to expose those in
local Authority care to risk
beyond our domestic reforms we are
working closely with our International
Partners to deter small boat arrivals
and put an end to the practices of
people smuggling and clandestine travel
into the United Kingdom
I entirely agree with the comments from
Lord Brown of Eaton under Hayward who
pointed out the nonsensical position
that albanians can prioritize themselves
by crossing the channel in a small boat
and on
um
on that basis
effectively uh jump the queue and it's
incumbent on us to prevent that sort of
self-selection and cue jumping
I must note that baroness prasha and
others Overlook the basic fact that not
all those who claim to be refugees are
actually refugees
it is not immoral to point this out as
Lord robathon stated we must be sensible
and not naive about this
while legal challenges are ongoing we
remain committed to delivering the
migration and economic development
partnership between the United Kingdom
and Rwanda
to address the shared International
challenge of illegal migration and break
the business model of the people
smuggling gangs
this policy does not subcontract or
Outsource our responsibilities to Rwanda
instead the United Kingdom and Rwanda
working together will help make the
immigration system fairer and ensure
that people are safe to enjoy the new
opportunities to develop It Is by
reforming the Asylum system and taking
bold International action to address the
global migration crisis that we can keep
providing protection for those who need
it through safe and legal routes
I would like to respond to the
assertions of Lord Brown of laterton on
our assessment which found Rwanda to be
a fundamentally safe and secure country
with a track record of supporting Asylum
Seekers
this is set out in the relevant country
policy and information notes which are
available on the gov.uk website these
assessments are kept under review and
are updated periodically to reflect any
significant new issues or evidence
we regularly Monitor and review the
situation Rwanda and they're working
closely with the foreign Commonwealth
and development office
last month the United Kingdom and France
signed a new agreement further to
bolster our combined efforts to prevent
the dangerous Channel Crossings
including through strength and
operational cooperation and investment
in cutting-edge surveillance technology
the UK remains committed to addressing
illegal migration with France via our
enduring relationship
we continue to engage with our French
friends at all levels political and
operational
supporting with the provision of
technology and sharing of intelligence
to meet our shared strategic aims
France and other EU countries are safe
countries unlike the UK have Asylum
systems themselves which provide
protection to those who need it
those in France
but I I didn't do so earlier he talks
about safe countries as if there's an
object and earlier he said there was an
obligation to claim Assad in the first
safe country he will of course be aware
that unhcr that is absolutely not the
law indeed if it was the refugee
convention would never have been signed
because countries neighboring conflict
areas which already take the bulk of of
refugees would never have signed it I
hear what the noble lady says can I
commend to the noble Lady of the
excellent policy exchange paper called
three essays on the morality of
assignment in that excellent paper
Professor Phyllis reminds us that um uh
he says this I'll read directly from the
paper
the Rwanda scheme I'm reading from page
14 the Rwanda scheme does not
subcontract anything the UK is a
founding party of the refugee convention
did not undertake to receive or process
or admit refugees it's contractual
undertaking and obligation is a to give
certain rights and privileges to those
refugees whom it has chosen to admit and
give and leave to stay
and B not to deport anyone to an unsafe
Third Country
foreign
with that argument
is that the refugee convention
imposes on us the duty to hear the claim
if we Deport someone to Rwanda on the
basis that even if their claim were
Justified that will not be established
and they will not be allowed to return
they will be
investigated in Rwanda to see if they
may have asylum in Rwanda but they will
not be unable to pursue their claim to
Asylum in this country that is clearly
contrary to the refugee convention
because I do to disagree with the noble
learning law that matter is currently
before the high court and the
government's position is clearly that it
is at odds with the assessment of the
noble and learned Lord
um
I I would crave the Indulgence of the
house to carry on for a few more moments
if I may
um
turning then to the questions in
relation to
climate change
and I'm terribly sorry the noble Lord
Lord Cormac were to Mrs Trent
um we will not remove anyone
uh to any other country where they would
face persecution or serious harm
um as a result of uh if their country
had ceased to exist as was a premised in
one of uh the noble Lords speeches
um it's always right in this context to
remember uh as uh pointed out by my
Naval friend Lord Lily
that um
the arrival by small boats put
significant pressure on local
authorities
the home office acknowledges The Strain
that dispersing Asylum Seekers is having
on many authorities and it's for this
reason that the home officers work in
collaboratively with local authorities
and Commercial Partners to agree
Regional and National plans on the
implementation for full Asylum dispersal
this process will enable us to continue
to meet our obligations to accommodate
destitute Asylum Seekers well not
overcrowding local areas
foreign
then to
the
um
forgive me I I really must I'm a friend
I really must make progress no I'm
afraid I really must make progress I'm
sorry to decline I'm sorry to decline
intervention I fear my Lord that we
really must make progress at this stage
we still have to hear from the the right
the um primate the Archbishop Academy we
must make some progress
all right
time I'm afraid does not permit me to
address all the issues raised by Noble
Lords however I fully understand that
this is and will remain an emotive issue
for for many
Although our compassion may be Limitless
our capacity resources and
infrastructures to help people are
finite
this country
this country has shown time and again
from those who arrived on the Kinder
transport as the noble Lord doves
rightly raised and the Ugandan Asians
expelled by the armeen to those fleeing
the present Dreadful conflict in Ukraine
that when people are suffering and they
need Sanctuary we Step Up
we extend the hand of friendship and
provide a welcome born of our natural
compassion
as the government has demonstrated we
are committed to maintaining that long
and proud tradition through safe and
legal roots and we will continue to do
what is right and help those who are in
most need as the noble Lord Lord Cormac
as a reference in this debate I
completely agree that refugees enrich
both our history and our present
at the same time the public expect us to
control migration uphold our immigration
laws and discourage those who would risk
their lives by making unsafe and
unnecessary Journeys to the UK across
the channel
as I hope I've made here today the
government approaches these
responsibilities with the greatest
seriousness and that will continue to be
the case
would he uh be able to undertake to
write to Noble laws who've spoken in
this debate to answer the questions he's
been unable to answer because of the
length of time that he's had available
yeah
I I would invite instead Noble Lords to
ask written questions in relation to the
points
my Lord I'm a former leader of the house
I have never ever seen such a reply from
a minister if a minister is unable to
respond in verbally then he or she must
reply in writing
very well actual right as requested
my Lord
keeping to my sense of compassion I
shall have compassion on Lord cormac's
train
and to my very best to be as brief as
possible and I will write where I don't
answer questions
probably not till after Christmas I have
higher claims
um what's going on
not a lot
first of all may I thank Noble Lords for
their extraordinary contributions I
can't refer to all the contributions
because there are so many that have been
so excellent
but it has been a remarkable debate I'm
very grateful I'm particularly grateful
uh to Lord so how to enable Lord Lord to
hurt her Noble baroness baroness twice
and also
um the uh right Reverend uh pray that
the bishop of Leicester who have all
contributed remarkably from their
experience and their and have
demonstrated the reasons why they are in
this house thank you
uh I secondly want I'm not going to
mention 90th birth oh I just have I'm
I'm not going to mention birthdays
um which came around increasingly
frequently but I have to say that I sit
in I sat in awe listening to Lord dubs
yeah and I'm sure that is true for the
entire house
his moral Authority vastly exceeds
anyone else's in this house going right
back to the Kinder transport and it has
been a great privilege for me and for
I'm sure everyone else here to engage
with him on this subject
uh this is as the naval Lord the
minister said quite rightly a very um
right a very uh emotive and very
difficult subject and I'm just going to
throw out a few headlines
I wonder given the complexity of the
subject I had that in there they drafted
me I took it out to one of my advisors
take took it out so I'm going to annoy
them by putting it back in I just wonder
don't we wouldn't it make more sense in
view of the level of difficulty of this
subject and its immense importance which
numerous Naval Lords have emphasized
very strongly if there was a separate
department for immigration which could
focus on this issue rather than having
it in the complexities of the home
office which as we know is one of the
most difficult offices to lead
which leads me to say that with uh
listening to Lord Murray I felt a great
um deal of sympathy uh it's he it's a
very new
um and complex system that is being
looked at which is under serious strain
as he said
but I think I would like to say to the
noble Lord the minister affirmation is
not evidence
and he made a number of affirmations
about what would be done what has been
done what is being done but certainly
other Noble Lords tried very hard
to go for evidence and I think in
letters that are written it would it's
important that we look at that I
sympathize with these legal difficulties
um anyone in the Church of England would
sympathize with people's legal
difficulties I've just be had a clergy
discipline measure dismissed thankfully
against me for not recognizing a
particular claimant who said he was the
living incarnation of the Lord God and I
I had ignored him more than a thousand
times and uh therefore I should be
dismissed from my post in a totally
straight days judgment after some months
the relevant judge dismissed the claim
uh and I would like to say about his
comment about the Archbishop of York and
Archbishop of current uh Canterbury
disagreeing with each other there's
nothing new about that it is different
from the iron discipline of the
conservative cabinet
but
we suffer what we must
and for Archbishop of York particularly
does
um
I'm
if we're going to break and this is a
venture into economics which with the
noble Lord horrorman the noble Lord Lord
Josiah I am very very nervous about
doing but I'm going to dance into the
Minefield and say that in my days in the
oil industry a long time ago then maybe
economics has changed it was always said
that the lowest cost producer would
always survive
there is such a thing as a law of supply
and demand
and uh if we have safe and legal Roots
we automatically become the lowest cost
reducer and that by itself will
completely undermine the business model
of the people smuggles I throw that out
as as probably a wrong answer but I'll
do my best
um I think also I do know that the noble
Lord the minister didn't actually answer
uh Bill Brown's question about what
about the assessment by the foreign
office and others about what's going on
in Rwanda
uh he said other things about Rwanda but
he didn't answer the question which was
put and I think it would be very useful
if he would write in his written answer
that he included an answer to the very
clear question that was put about why
the government's assessment is so
different from its professional foreign
office advisors I think we'd need to see
some uh uh answers on that
I'm looking for the clock I've got eight
minutes
um
moving on from that I do very strongly
agree with Noble Lords who made a very
strong and clear argument that what we
need to do is talk about Asylum as
distinct from migration they are very
very different things Asylum happens
because of what happens elsewhere
migration happens because of what we
choose to happen particularly around
students for instance whereas we know
most places don't confuse the two in
quite the same way
the question on whether we allow or even
encourage even possibly
compel people in appropriate positions
to take employment while they are
waiting for claims is one again that I'm
afraid I don't think was answered and I
think that is that was put forward by a
very large number of noble Lords and I
think it's an extremely important
question
um
I agree very much with the noble
baroness uh baroness barrage and the
noble baroness various loveford that I
was wrong to suggest that we need to
replace the 1951 convention it actually
we need a new convention and keeps the
1951 convention I think the point on
that is a very powerful one and it was
an error on my part
uh
I think
I'm going to return to Lord Lily's
comments enabled Lord Lilly's comments
if I may
I sort of used my hotline to God
but as he referred to it but I regret to
say I appear to have been disconnected
for not having paid the bill
and all I got when I pressed button
three was a long recorded message
so I went back to the Bible
who is my neighbor I in fact in my first
speech as with the other members of this
bench it may seem unusual but we did
actually all only quote the Bible and no
other form of hotline
who is my neighbor
we can answer the question by saying
everyone's my neighbor but it is not a
logical consequence of that that
everyone must come here
The Logical consequence is that we need
to do all that we can to ensure that
those who are suffering find their
suffering reduced that may well not
include bringing them to a different
country from the one in which they've
grown up my long experience now of over
20 years in Conflict zones particularly
in sub-Saharan Africa is that almost no
one wants to be a refugee
they want to stay at home
they want to build their country as we
do
they love the United Kingdom but not all
of them want to stay here
we can see that when thanks to the good
work of the home office last
um some of the uh we had almost 700
Anglican communion bishops from 162
countries coming here
with much help
not one of them overstayed
many of them live in war zones
most of them are not paid ever but live
off the money they get from tilling some
ground
while at the same time working under
enormous personal risk in intense
poverty and much Danger
who is my neighbor is faced is not only
dealt with by Asylum
but also by stabilization and it is a
great pity that the government has
almost abolished the stabilization unit
in the fcdo
by development
and creating hope locally by addressing
the kind of awful and heartbreaking
situation spoken of by uh Noble baroness
baroness Nichols
that is what stops people coming
the noble baroness baroness barrage did
mention the upcoming Nigerian election
I'm not going to develop that theme but
it's something with which again I
entirely agree with that and have spoken
recently to the foreign office about
I will answer the particular questions
of Lord Roberton uh
by letter if I may take that because
they're not all directly connected with
the service with this place
um and you know I've got a lot of Carol
senses and in order to just pick up the
question you did ask and and I think the
level Lord Lily asked about what are we
doing about it it may not be the novel
lordly but what are we doing to increase
uh attendance at churches we're working
extremely hard yesterday evening we had
200 people or 100 people in my Chapel in
order to hear the good news of the
Gospel of Jesus Christ
and we uh I'm very glad there are
atheists here in such profusion because
it gives them a chance to hear that and
they might just be converted you never
know but I don't think so loading at the
looking at the naval Lord will Cashman
we'll see uh uh in our post-retirement
existence whether we exist or not
um
finally
policy Exchange in my last minute
the policy exchange document is
interesting
and is certainly worth reading I commend
it to the house
I don't agree with it any more than I do
agreed at the time with an earlier
policy exchange document
which suggested that the best way to
deal with leveling up in the north and
particularly the city of Liverpool where
I was living at the time was to move the
entire population of Liverpool to
Cambridge
that was in 2008.
uh that was not very popular in
Liverpool I didn't consult those in
Cambridge
but I do think policy exchange have a
valuable function as provoking ideas but
not always quite as valuable a function
in solving problems
once again my lords thank you so much to
the whole house for a remarkable debate
for a huge number of wise ideas which I
will be going through and we will
consider uh at Great length note within
uh within the church
uh and with that I wish you a good
weekend and thank you very much
this motion be
resolved that a penny will say content
country not content the contents have it
my lords I'd beg to move that the house
do now adjourn
the house too now adjourn
foreign
of Lord sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]
House of Lords sound
[Laughter]